sir sir sir are you sorry sir sir sir
sure sir sir sir sir sir
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dump big massive dumps donald trump
insisted multiple times
that it was massive dumps that led him
to lose the election which is just
[Music]
big massive dumps
dumps dumps
dumps dumps
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
what is going on here
what is going what is going on here
it's just beyond parody massive dumps
cost them the election
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
big massive dumpsters
who thinks he's smarter than you why who
thinks he's smarter than you why is he
smarter than you this is
[Music]
is
[Applause]
that might come as a shot
[Music]
[Applause]
jones has fake callers jones has fake
callers jones has fake colors
[Music]
[Music]
look at that look at that
trump was doing this with his personal
toilet
toilets
and
times showers times
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly in sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're not dave pegman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe wrote him
[Music]
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.
and 99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
eight or 11 bucks
back down
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't want me to be
is
[Music]
well welcome everybody we have a very
special event tonight yes it's a trump
rally yes he's going to be extremely
orange yes the crowd will be far smaller
than trump claims yes mike pillow is
there yes trump will lie
but
donald trump may announce his 2024
candidacy at tonight's rally now this is
just conjecture speculation and rumor so
take it for what it's worth almost
nothing but
those rumors
that conjecture
uh is indeed that tonight donald trump
may announce that he's running in 2024
um the perspective is sort of twofold
one
the political analysis is that given
everything that's going on and seemingly
uh donald trump sort of losing his grip
on the republican party to a degree that
it may be to his advantage to announce
sooner than later uh on the other hand
also rumor that trump's new uh plane he
got a plane job a paint job on his plane
i just call it a plane job
uh which rep again it's all rumor
um has 20 24 flags on it or something
like that
um so that's kind of like what's going
on
and we are very very soon going to know
more this rally is in anchorage alaska
donald trump is campaigning against
lisa murkowski
who he's campaigning for i don't even
know like it doesn't even really matter
trump just wants to hurt lisa murkowski
because she is not a full-blown trump
republican
and uh
it's sort of like a high school gym
vibes
maybe maybe more like uh
i guess like like a community college
auditorium or something like that
um and reportedly on the heels of the
assassination
of former japanese prime minister shinzo
abe
there is like an extra layer of security
you've got your secret service you've
got your anchorage police tsa is doing
security this is all a report i mean i'm
not on the ground but trump has also
brought in sort of like some tight shirt
muscle-bound private security in
addition to secret service now i don't
know if that is exactly as described
how how much do you trust secret service
if you bring in
the tight shirt
tattoo security guys you know
um
but that's a different question
maybe for a different day
right side broadcasting is covering the
rally here is newsmax which will also be
covering the rally trump expected to
speak in just about 45 minutes or so
uh will there be a glitchy trump today
that we don't know we've endorsed jp
right j.d mandel you know something
really funny um
the other day i interviewed a guy named
jeffrey mandel
and as i always do with every guest
before we go live i s i confirm the
pronunciation of his last name and i say
hey jeff is is your last name pronounced
in mandel
and he said it is and i was like oh just
like just like jp mandel right
and uh he got the reference he got the
reference thankfully so it was not a
moment of complete humiliation for me in
front of yet another guest let's listen
briefly to mike pillow we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines last two days
they're to know every all the hope in
this country they're going to know what
we're going to do what what what has to
be done what has been done and everyone
is and they're going to be educated
educate on what they can do as you know
the legislators they i get all the
legislators and the politics
legislatures save this country
absolutely they were all scared sort of
like when um marjorie taylor green said
jewish space
fann i mean lasers did karen come sorry
shame on you karen fan what have you
done it's just you know she might not be
a rusty bowers but she's a blocker you
know these things these people block we
don't know why make it a lot of sense
in history we'll look back
and all of you watching right now if
you're a legislator you can now make a
move now you get one chance to be a hero
or you're going to be a traitor there's
not going to be anything in between
pillow is very very sick you can tell i
don't want anyone in this country or the
world for that matter to be able to say
possible deniability what election crime
let's hope that applies to charges on
pillow as well right i think i think
people are starting to recognize
the election was stolen
it's taken almost two years but we're
starting to get a trickle of people
thinking about considering evaluating
whether
even a single dead person voted
presidential election you know it's kind
of hard to believe but as time has gone
on and we have seen
what a poor job joe biden and kamala
harris are doing pamela you guys know
about agit prop this is agit pillow not
the most popular elected officials in
history
i think i think
that's what had to happen when i said
i'd say that you're exactly right you're
spot on this stuff has happened yeah so
we're standing by for donald trump um
he's scheduled to speak in 45 minutes
the there is a major announcement
expected from trump tonight and we will
ban men no no no no not that not that
just
there's a rumor he might announce that
he's running for president in 2024. so
everybody is welcome this is not a
stream where we limit the audience based
on age
um
gender
sexual orientation
political orientation
um
whether or not you like yellow mustard i
mean we just every everybody's welcome
everybody is welcome here and we are
expecting
a very powerful stream and many many
things to look at first super chat is
from hudson markel
says david sir i'm turning 18 in a few
days and i'm excited to vote for the
democrats this midterm sure yeah well
sir i appreciate that
and i look forward to your vote adexi
says sir
i only installed twitch so i could give
you bezos bucks didn't know i'd have to
subscribe every month i doubt i'm the
only one may want to inform all yeah the
twitch prime subscriptions
they give you bezos bucks to give me for
free
but it doesn't renew automatically you
have to remember to renew the bezos
bucks they want you to forget about it
they want you to forget about it all
right let's rev i have so much material
for you guys
from
the rally
um it turns out alaska's pretty wild so
let me first just thank a few people i
want to say thank you to eric bigford
bickford adam taylor
for signing up on my website
joinpakman.com new members 1 and 2 as
you can see over here also want to say
thank you to juan who has just gifted a
membership and jason
sickmeyer who has also gifted a
membership that puts us at four remember
we have free memberships to give away
there are about 300 people right now in
line you can request your membership for
free uh by just filling out the three
field form at davidpakman.com free
membership
you can gift memberships at
joinpakman.com and of course today's
coupon code is indict why well it's a
trump rally
i don't think i have to explain to you
why the coupon code is indict there's no
shortage of people at this event
who deserve
an indictment or two over on twitch i
want to say thanks to blueberry babe dug
it sam the sleeves bag k shreds shiny
socks kind af
green man at 28 months
deeper shades of house great to see you
lars
what
uh
we have captain smiles
beth graham do you grok
valerie fisher that's 13 13 plus four
four plus three is seven nothing to
carry and a one
puts us at 17. i very much appreciate
that travis says hey bro can't believe i
found you on here remember me we met at
a dog park about a year ago best makeout
session i've ever had crazy i found you
on here hope you're doing well well
travis i uh have never been to a dog
park and i've never made out with a man
so it couldn't have been me
uh maybe some other host i don't know
who it was
uh but a very very interesting story
that's for sure
all right let's get into some material
here are our friends the good liars they
spoke to a proud
general flynn digital soldier digital
soldier check this out i think what
everyone would want to know if they came
across you they saw your your q mobile
and they saw you they would want to know
you know
are you serious
yes i go all over this country spreading
the truth
you can't hold your ego up and carry the
truth at the same time because i had to
accept the fact
bushes were my heroes i wrote a poem i
don't know if i have a copy handy oh i
think i do yeah let's hear that i am now
a proud general flynn digital soldier
god help me with these words after much
prayer after the attacks of 9 11. i know
the truth about those attacks now my
prayer is that all enemies foreign and
domestic that are responsible for that
evil on that day and all subsequent evil
that arose from it are punished and
there you have it people are reading
beautiful poetry
yeah um our friends uh davrum and uh
jason always doing a good job now you
know what's funny about videos like this
is not funny but there's this weird
thing where
i'll i'll play a video like this and
i'll go you know this is really an
example of stupidity these are
uneducated stupid people and then people
will go david it's that's it's not a
question of that it's it's it's it's
it's mental illness it's radicalization
whatever okay so then i go you know this
is clearly politics aside someone who
is delusional that's a mental illness
and people go david you're stigmatizing
mental illness you know most mentally
ill people don't believe stuff like this
so it's you can't say it's it's mental
so okay all right this is extremism and
radicalization and people go dude it's
not just that these these are mentally
ill ignorant people okay it's all of
these things
it's all of these things
i mean it's elements of all of these
things i think is where we have to kind
of land on it let's listen a little bit
more to what mike pillow is saying
you have to fix 2021st and he has never
backed down to that and he's never
conceded he has been firm that he wants
to correct 2020 recognizing that 2022 is
just a couple months away and the
primaries have already happened so we
have to we have to build the airplane as
we fly
i like that analogy we're building it we
might not be perfect going into 2022 we
might only have it for seems high as a
kite machine's gone but we're building
that for to save our country and then
get our right politicians back including
our great president donald trump that is
right and i see just in the work that i
do i'm very encouraged what work does
she do people who have stepped up to
volunteer to become full workers too
yeah the guy on the right does look
completely wasted make sure that uh
their their precincts their individual
precincts are safe and i think that
people are working to clean up election
laws and i i just think we're in a
better people are cleaning up election
law what are they they use these
euphemisms that are they they end up
being completely meaningless completely
completely meaningless thanks to t.h
gustafsson as well as tall cross numeral
whistle
oak city peter and crack two eggs for
the twitch prime subscription putting us
at 22. also i have to say
thank you to jordan cottony who just
signed up on my website joinedpakman.com
and is new member number 23 and lastly
thanks to people gifting membership web
web memberships on my website lawrence
quartowitz just sent a gift johnny
minogue also known as johnny from boston
and seth sword out
all gifting memberships on my website
putting us at 26 at this very very early
uh stage of the game oh and also thanks
to pilot dog for the twitch prime
subscription
super chats a whole bunch of them
uh elements of mental illness and
elements of extremism i i agree it's
both
obama
obama yep i've got that one ready to go
uh let's look at a couple of other
things our friend ron philippkowski
is all over all over this stuff uh mike
pillow has a new plan to get trump
reinstated we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines no no no no
it's a different plan
but remember originally it was going to
be august of 2021.
now it's august of 2022. this is so
exciting because
it's just all going to lead up everybody
too and i've got to say this august 20th
and 21st the biggest he's doing his
zavozium i've been this country in our
lifetime i believe it's the most
important event you're ever for
in our lifetime what no the world cup's
in november dude this is gonna do this
will be in springfield missouri live
stream to the world
and it's a two day event it's invite
only you guys will be there yeah you
said that it's an invite only so it's in
spring spring missouri yeah springfield
missouri is so important they'll be if
you know the invites will be going out
these will be influencers podcasters
grassroots uh the grassroots are going
to be there it'll be uh
church leaders okay and when we do this
everybody imagine every state will be
getting up there saying uh you know
here's our footprint you're all going to
hear what the good going where's our
hope you know and then the next i can't
tell if it's another one of these cyber
cyber symposiums or whether it's like a
religious event it's all very very
strange hey here's something i should
consider bill o'reilly is offering a
concierge program where you can ask him
for life advice and he'll get back to
you within 24 hours so i get a lot of
questions about people traveling the
world
and i because i've been to 84 countries
i can steer you into good places and
tell you if you get ripped off right if
you want a whole grilled fish okay
um
in sorrento italy
you ask bill o'reilly
bill
where do i go and what should i expect
to pay for a beautiful grilled fish
on the amalfi coast and he'll tell you
i get questions about consumer problems
right if you're saying like okay so i
need an espresso machine
and i know a lot of espresso machines
don't do well with dark roast beans
they're too oily
is there any espresso machine that bill
o'reilly would recommend if you are a
fan of dark roast somebody's contractor
is doing a and then i can steer them i
get financial yeah if you're wondering
how to hang joists
you ask bill o'reilly and he'll tell you
exactly how to build that questions i
cannot give financial or medical advice
right medical he won't do okay that's
fair but i can tell you what i would do
all right so life is complicated
for a concierge membership on bill
o'reilly.com you have me
to answer your questions which we do
within 24 hours
i mean
it's pretty amazing so you might want to
think about it yeah that's something
that's something you guys should uh
definitely think about okay all right
good
um
okay i'm gonna skip this one women at
the trump rally are asked what issues
concern them oh this should be this
should be pretty good
what's the most important issue that you
guys are concerned about as alaska oh
space force all right
in alaska the number one issue is space
force there you go dark healing
the support of our veterans the healing
i'm sorry trafficking specifically what
kind of trafficking uh human trafficking
are you worried about our southern
border
yes
in alaska
they're most concerned with the u.s
mexico border that's interesting
everything
i think eventually they'll end up going
back to their own countries with nasara
jasar kicking in
with what what did she say nasara jasara
what was that
countries with nasara jasara kiki
nassar jazar
am i the stupid one what does that mean
nassar jazar nascar
tikka masala no no no
no sarah josara
jafar from aladdin
it's numerology oh hold on
nasara
jafara
i'm not seeing anything about that
guess sarah let me let me listen to once
more hold on i think eventually they'll
end up going back to their own countries
with nasara jasar
nassar jazar
i don't know what that is
wow
here's a guy at a trump rally
singing trump's praises
look what he did for us i mean come on
man
he's a he's a businessman
this is what my newborn daughter sounds
like after she's had four ounces of milk
he's throwing people up they can't they
don't know where they're at because he
how is he even doing that trump it's
like a like a
how is he doing that he knows ins and
outs of business
i can't even do that in
where i can't tell if that's in the
throat or in the where is that
he got all of our prices down our taxes
down i might be able to do it if i let
me see if i can do it with a little bit
i go
i don't know how that is even
biologically possible my gas down our
food down
the man's dream
oh god
this is gonna be quite a night
that's a ruptured larynx okay well i
don't believe i have that at least not
at this point in time that's probably
why i can't do it all right other super
chats coming in david how would you
watch less politics but still be
involved in politics oh just stop
watching any political news
but get involved in local races i mean i
think that would be the way to do it
national economic security and recovery
act nasara oh okay nasara
it was proposed in the 1990s by harvey
francis barnard is there anything going
on right now related to this nasara does
anybody know
that guy was doing tibetan throat
singing somehow i don't think so
somehow i don't think so i want to say
thanks to some people gifting
subscriptions on my website david
colabella just gifted one kevin gouldy
just gifted one and david colabella
gifted a second that puts us at 30. also
want to say thanks to pulber who has
just signed up via twitch prime and is
number 31. folks we have a goal today
of 100 new website members and twitch
subscribers
okay
we're already at 31. now percentage-wise
31 out of a hundred
three divided by ten is point three
zero zero
ten divided by three one that's thirty
one and a half percent of the way to 100
31 out of 100 is 30 no that doesn't
sound right that's weird
anyway it's roughly a third of the way
okay it's roughly a third of the way
and i would love
for you to go to join pacman.com this is
my website
it's not the best website but it's mine
and you can use the code indict
which will just do wonders for you look
at these prices not league only legal in
the contiguous 48 so if you're in hawaii
or today's rally location of alaska
uh you can't do it there you can't do it
there no i'm kidding it's legal
everywhere completely legal everywhere
all right let's continue our tour of the
insanity happening at the trump rally
sarah palin
resurfaced and she's completely out of
her mind
might not surprise you to our leaders
not being able to
tell us
they don't know what a woman is
and we will ban men
hey all you alaskan chicks out there
maybe you can show them tell them what
real woman is show them what a woman is
oh god
sarah palin wants the alaskan women to
show liberal men what makes them women
can you imagine
can you imagine what is happening here
unbelievable
is she pointing at someone who's
currently showing what makes her a woman
biologically
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the mama grizzlies hey the leader
of the pack in my world my right hand
man she chris perry she's the mama
grizzly whom i look to she's sitting
here somewhere my campaign manager my
best friend my right hand man chris
perry all right well whatever here we go
my dad
no he was all about no you stiffen your
spine you use what they throw at you as
fuel
let it strengthen and fortify you
and you fight for what is right well my
dad's words exactly were
don't retreat reload
wow a principled and defiant message of
unity
[Applause]
horrible
um they used the pandemic uh oh oh god
look at this
this is life changing what's coming up
here in the midterms the change that are
needed and it's no longer democrat
versus republican
this is all about control versus freedom
it's
[Applause]
it's good versus evil
it is a spiritual battle
[Music]
[Applause]
they use the plandemic as an example
the pandemic in order to achieve a goal
of controlling you look wow full
full-blown insanity
complete and total full just full-blown
insanity
thanks to doug it
for gifting five subscriptions on twitch
also thanks to hey that's my llama dave
schmidt and on what planet
oh god
looks like they're going to a new
they're restarting their stream i guess
what the heck
why is it over that's weird all right
we'll stick over here for now anyway
that's eight putting us at 39. i very
much appreciate that let's look at some
super chats trump is a cheater he
cheated on his wife on his golf games on
his taxes and on occasion he cheats on
his elections there you go
so glad for all you do david especially
during the presidential nonsense of 17
to 20 if this fat orange goblin runs for
president again we're going to have
another long fight on our hands isn't
that the truth
do you the mama grizzlies should teach
transgender yeah i i guarantee i'm not a
betting man but i would bet today trump
says that he will stop teachers from
teaching transgender what that means we
still don't know
sir the last time someone in alaska
tried to show folks what a woman is they
got arrested for indecent exposure my
thoughts exactly
i remember when i thought it couldn't
get any crazier than sarah palin i know
i remember
in 2012 in 20 2008
it was sort of like
there's never going to be a dumber
person with a real shot at power than
sarah palin and then
we were very wrong very wrong david sir
thank you for all you do in the
perfectly timed dry humor congrats on
your beautiful daughter daughter thank
you a mandolin
amandee lin
hello david and friends not sure if the
amazon series the boys is up your alley
but the new season has been mocking
trump and the white right overtly
thought you'd appreciate it it's
impressive i heard it's very good i have
not seen it myself
they switched to rumble oh okay let's
see here
bright side broadcasting
[Music]
rumble i've never seen a rumble live
stream let's see what's going on
right now on rumble our app and our
website so thanks for making that
migration we'll kind of uh recap the
today's stories here in a few minutes as
uh okay all right so we've got the
newsmax feed
and then we've got the uh rumble thing
going so okay we're gonna do fine we're
gonna do fine i think we'll be we'll be
beautifully fine with this uh with this
rally
other super chats dumping in david sir
you need to make a sound clip of you
imitating trump when he said chocolate
cake i actually you know what's funny
about that
small fuzzy ma sent it to me
um
i did not think this was funny but
people keep writing to me about that
they liked it check this out you spoke
english at all it's a story i think i've
never told a big crowd like this but
i didn't think he spoke english because
he wouldn't even say hello we had a very
good relationship until coveted and then
i said forget it
that was
a step too far but we did and we
respected each other
we respected each other but i said
president
chocolate cake at mar-a-lago chocolate
cake beautiful chocolate cake
okay i mean i didn't think it was sort
of a throw away but
all right there was that that was
interesting
rsbn anchor dude just used the words the
stream will end so you will be forced to
switch to these other platforms that
doesn't sound like freedom to me
hi from the philly philippines the mango
capital of the pacific you know one
thing i thought about doing i guess like
hold on is it
ah mango
so i guess there are like extremely rare
and delicious mangoes in i believe it's
afghanistan
and you can actually order them i
thought about getting some
special high-end mangoes and maybe we
could try them on stream
other super chats coming on in
well well well gay jews boy gas prices
up food two dollar down
so would you say this is truth
absolutely i i truly couldn't have said
it better myself
that is an absolute
i i just can't imagine
anything more accurate than that all
right let me thank people
who are currently
signing up because i don't want to miss
anybody chrono rick just pledged on
uh twitch and we have
an insane number of people getting
memberships on my website i want to say
thanks to roby littlefield as well as
audrey
summer
robert jansen
and jeanette geisler
all who just grabbed memberships on my
website joinedpakman.com that puts us at
44
and then the following people gifting
memberships remember if you want a free
membership just go to davidpakman.com
free membership
and there's a line i think it's about
325 people right now but we have a bunch
to give away ryan gunter with a gift
uh who else do we have here desiree de
long with a gift
david colabella with another gift david
colabella with another gift that's four
jason sickmeyer is five cheryl white is
six
david colabella is seven
that puts us at 51. 51 if you can
believe it
like on an airplane with the oxygen
masks where they say put it on yourself
before helping others get yourself a
membership
before you start gifting them that's
just my recommendation all right let's
look at a couple other elements here
um let's see what we've got
from the trump rally
uh okay that may be it here let's go
over to this next one oh this is where
we were oh so they did another prayer at
the rally and as as at previous rallies
they do a prayer
and they re they say our president
donald trump father we thank you
for our president
donald j trump
[Music]
[Applause]
father we thank you
that you used him for your glory we
thank you for the decisions he made in
this country
and we bless him today we bless his
family
we thank you for him
and we joined together and asked that
you would continue to use president
trump for your glory
it's not that different to think trump
is currently the president
than to think that jim jones was really
you know this
pseudo deity that he professed himself
to be i mean it's all it's all it's all
sick it's all equally sick
in my
humble opinion
um
juan who has been gifting some
memberships
he called in with a voicemail just now
let's listen to what he had to say
hey david it's juan i got a question
i was probably
fooled
brainwashed whatever you want to call it
by the right wing whoa
when this guys have been a right winger
calling in for a while has he just been
deprogrammed is that what happened
all the riots took place and uh
stuff like that
and i was watching a lot of the right
wing stuff tim poole and all these other
streamers
yeah that probably happened because i
wasn't very smart
no i think when it comes to politics and
very smart actually i don't think i'm
very smart when it comes to a lot of
things
my question is
now that i'm watching
for example your show and kyle kalinski
and all that how do i know i'm not
bringing being brainwashed by watching
that material because obviously i don't
know how to discern
things very well right this is so the
fur this is a beautiful beautiful
beautiful message so here's the deal
um
i encourage people
to fact check
to fact check me
to think for themselves
to
um
i will never tell you
what that i provide any kind of ultimate
truth
and that's a big difference compared to
a lot of these right wingers
i'm giving you a perspective and i
encourage you
to test my perspective
test it
and the self-awareness juan i mean
congratulations the people should be
coming to me with tears in their eyes
and saying
sure are you sorry sir
you have just stumbled upon
uh
you've leveled up epistemologically
okay so
you have to
trust but verify or or you know use
whatever
term you want
but i encourage you to see if the things
i say are accurate
don't take my word for it
um
[Music]
to go to something totally different i
think this is eric from math mass
calling about math
uh or something let's see
yeah hey david it's here for math i'm
watching right now it's massage
n-e-f-a-r-a-o-g in the beginning for
global it's a gold-backed uh
currency to get rid of the uh
central banks that have been robbing us
from illegal taxes oh god so a
gold-backed currency
is going to get people to go back to
their countries i think is what that
woman said i mean that's that's pretty
full-on bonkers
uh i just don't know that i see that
as anything that's ever going to happen
it sounds pretty nuts sounds pretty nuts
thanks to claudia valentine for signing
up at joinpackman.com your new member
number 52 today also thanks to crimson
as well as jay tandaway for the twitch
prime subscriptions numbers 53 and 54.
let's look at a couple of other video
clips here's a very very strange sort of
press conference trump did in vegas last
night their property is unbelievable
their cars as an example are unlocked to
prevent criminals from breaking the
windows let's just unlock we don't want
the cars broken into
they say take my car they say they say
take my car and hopefully it'll be
returned to me undamaged how about that
[Music]
drop boxes
okay
kind of a weird statement to make
we got drug use down 18 in the white
house
with an effort headed up by our great
first lady she worked very hard on that
safety
cepha hyde trump claims he's the victim
of a racist prosecutor
and really mean it in many cases however
racist prosecutors should
also be vigorously investigated for
their brazen violation of federal civil
rights laws
it's happening to me with a racist
attorney general in new york who
campaigned solely on the fact that she
hates orange people she would get donald
trump i'm gonna get him he knew nothing
about me i said who is this woman
she crazy a little bit no a lot
it's been going on for years as
violent crime got worse and worse and
worse man a rhino named mitt romney
here
here trump delivers a message of unity
[Applause]
we have to stop
fighting with each other and unify
that was happening during the greatest
period i believe in our country's
history in many ways
just before covet came in from china and
that's where it came from wuhan came
from muan
it can happen again
we were more unified just before that
everybody was happy was everybody happy
right before kovitt i don't really
remember it that way
when somebody says not really it means
they want to do it
and by the way it continues they still
want to defund the police you know
they're trying to say well not really
not really when somebody's saying not
really that means they want to do it
if you want to stop drugs coming into
this country you'll have to do what i
say
if you want to stop drugs coming into
this country and therefore stop a major
portion of crime
because a large portion of crime is
caused by drugs you'll have to
do what i say and you really have no
other choice you have no choice but to
do what trump says
but to do what i'm suggesting you do and
it's got to be done soon it's got to be
done now don't wait because millions of
people will die
if you okay
couple super chats coming in hey david
take it from me not all travis's are
weird what's your opinion on musicals
are you a broadway goer now that you're
in the city
uh well so i've not gone to any broadway
shows since the pandemic
i'm not
the biggest on broadway
uh i did see avenue q
off broadway i don't know it's like on
you know one of those smaller theaters
like on well off-broadway you know maybe
it was like
40
high 40s low 50s
and um i saw kind of like a modern romeo
and juliet
which was okay but it was like uh four
hours long it's like i i just don't i
just don't want it and i i can sit and
read for four hours
i can work on show stuff for four hour i
just i don't need a four hour musical
you know i just really don't
it was a little long
a little long
bay photo says i think if trump
announces a 2024 run early it
complicates things for republicans
however would it be bad for dems if
trump announces a 2024 before biden
announces if he won't run again now i
don't think that really will make a
difference i do think joe biden should
say soon
whether he is running for re-election
you know they keep saying he intends to
i don't believe he's going to run
and i'm going to talk a little bit about
on mond on monday about why i believe
that he should make the declaration
sooner than later
thank you to mallory karchia as well as
stephen garnett who just signed up at
joinpackman.com using the coupon code
indict
also thank you to tiffany mclay
tiffany gifting a membership
and thanks to simon reed for gifting a
membership numbers 57 and 58.
appreciate it so much so much use
today's coupon code indict
to save
massively
massively
at joinpakman.com
as many of you know
we
are a
viewer supported program
and every single membership every single
revenue source other than website
memberships has been taken away
capriciously in the past oh god who's
this oh nobody okay
uh we had youtube adpocalypse
we had the facebook fiasco
we had the twitch termination
we had the instagram
imbroglio i think is the word i would
use
um
but membership has been the steady
source
and so i would love for you to sign up
at joinpakman.com it's super easy you
can type in these these coupon codes
should be illegal like when i type in
indict and you must spell it correctly
magical things can happen
magical magical magical things
all right and we are we are moments away
from donald trump here let's see what
the ambiance is like
oh they're doing the wave okay very very
nice they're trying to turn our strong
babies into femme boys and defend doors
when will they stop i know it's it's a
trap it's truly a tragedy
what they are doing
let's look at a couple other things here
while we have time
um
palin stuff
trump won alaska but pillow says votes
were stolen from him there you all know
here in alaska over 29 000 votes were
stolen from donald trump stole
so
it happened everywhere in our country
and uh as you all know i've said it we
have to get rid of the machines and the
voting machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines okay
uh very good you know i've actually been
looking at upgrading my espresso machine
i really have because i've had the same
one now for
uh let me think here i've had it for six
years and it's great but i've been
thinking of upgrading it but because of
the lawsuit against all machines i don't
want it to end up in prison
you know
so i i'm holding off on the new espresso
machine at least for the time being
don't want to do anything too too crazy
okay
let's look at um
let's listen to a couple other
voicemails that are coming in here
did you does anybody understand i heard
understood the word weather
does anybody know what on earth that was
about
very unusual voicemail here's another
one
hey david patman this is kevin dukes
from branson missouri and i just want to
say we love your show and everything i
loved your remix this morning or this
afternoon
about
the donald trump and the watermelon
thing that was pretty funny that my own
thing so um anyway i do think that
donald trump will announces
does anybody know what that's about
trump and the melon
i don't know what what what are people
watching
did i do something about trump and melon
mangoes you think oh you think that was
about mangoes oh but that didn't even
have anything to do with trump
the watermelon thing damn i don't even
know what's happening on my own show i'm
i don't know sure tonight if he doesn't
know this tonight i'll be shocked
because they've been talking about it on
the news and all that yeah and they're
talking about how
that donald trump will probably announce
it after
the election that's what i've heard so i
don't know if that's going to happen i i
just want to know your thoughts
and also the january 6 committee seems
like they're getting pretty much a lot
of detail and how
like him grabbing the steering wheel and
all that what do you think of that and
also um
i think it probably happened you give me
a shout out or just a shout out to out
on your live that would be great as well
okay shouting you out right now thank
you very very much
david sir
so nice to finally give you a call
sir sir i appreciate your show
i have three big questions if you can
answer them oh my god first question is
do you think the former president donald
trump is incriminating himself further
by continuing even to this day of
voluntarily perpetuating that the 2020
election was stolen no
my second question
as a christian i'm personally disgusted
with the overwhelming anti-christian
actions from the biggest con dawn
and i was wondering
why do so many christian groups and
leaders endorse him and because he says
he's against abortion portray him almost
as if he's a gift sent from god yeah
and then my last question is um
do you think they will remove ketchup
from his prison if he gets convicted
thank you so much david
what
i don't even know what that last one's
about
super chat's coming in zero hope in a
faux post facts post-truth world it's
not a coincidence that the most common
phrase to start a sentence now is i feel
that yeah i never use that language
myself
i'll say things like
based on everything i've seen and read
i try to avoid i feel like unless it's
really something that's about feelings
like i feel like you attacked me right i
mean maybe
maybe it wasn't intended as an attack i
feel like you attacked me i feel like
you were condescending
but other than that i say
based on everything i've read
based on all the information i've
reviewed up until this point oh trump
and the the wall catch okay i got you i
got i totally forgot about the ketchup
reference
i'd be happy to adopt your espresso
machine and defend it with my life
machines or people too
well said
if trump doesn't announce a 24 run you
should play the curb theme when he's
finished but if he does say he's running
imperial march all the way yeah i think
that's a fair fair plan for today i like
that idea all right we are moments away
from donald trump in alaska he's there
just to spite lisa murkowski he has
nothing he has no business in
alaska um
but he's there to attack lisa murkowski
and support her opponent i don't even
know who it is i don't even care to look
i'm sure he'll tell us her name he'll
probably mispronounce it but
at least at least in theory um
we'll get you know some sense of it
trump pronouncing names is very very
dicey i've had more investigations than
jesse james billy that could
a rhino named mitt romney
we've endorsed jp right j.d mandel swami
vivek
yep
yeah okay so anyway we i mean i'll have
to research on my own what the woman's
name really is i see i believe it's a
woman from what people are saying in the
chat all right thanks to ad space
available
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 59
i also want to say thank you to fergal
cosgrave who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code indict
matthew bork
thank you
and josh samsel
number 61 and 62
people are blowing up the website it is
on fire
hello from germany says memestar world
war 3 more likely to happen if trump is
going to be the next possible president
uh yeah i i mean listen
i don't
you know with all the stuff it's a big
thing now to attack other candidates as
warmongers like trump said hillary's are
going to be she'll start five wars and
she probably wouldn't
uh and then trump said i'm not gonna do
anything but i'm the strongest guy on
the military and the strongest guy in
general but i'm not gonna get us into
any conflicts okay and then biden's
gonna start a million wars and of course
biden has no interest in starting any
wars so i try to kind of take a step
back from the
world war three type stuff
but through sheer incompetence trump
could accidentally trigger some horrible
conflict
um
yeah
elissa says congrats on the new bundle
of joy thank you so much
i appreciate that
uh a lot happening at once to keep up
with let's look at a couple other
um elements here
let me see oh ron phillipkowski let's
see what else he's got he's got a whole
team i believe down at the rally
let's see what we've got here
oh no we already reviewed that and we
might actually be caught up on this
stuff which would be great because the
rally's about to start
yeah okay
all right good i think we're in pretty
good shape i'm pleased with where we are
right now let's put it that way if you
were legend of alex says if you're
distressed by anything external the pain
is not due to the thing itself but to
your estimate of it and this you have
the power to revoke at any moment that's
marcus aurelius yeah victor frankel
actually
had a similar quote
um
let me see if i can find it
yeah victor frankel's quote was
everything can be taken but one thing
to choose one's attitude in any given
set of circumstances to choose one's own
way yeah it's a similar concept from the
stoics very much so
very very much so all right couple other
voicemails here
hey david i was wondering if you noticed
uh during the trump rally in uh
alaska they're uh
using the wave to as uh in the crowd
and the their tactics their uh the
cameraman jesus
has a wide angle lens on it and then
when he wants to show the crowd without
them and they ask me he zooms in on one
corner of the crowd and then pans just a
short little bit and then
zooms back out slowly and it looks like
you know a huge crowd but
i don't think that crowd's that big i
don't even know because i mean from the
regular angle i think you can only you
can only see about exactly it's it's not
a particularly large venue i mean it
wouldn't shock me for trump to claim
that there's you know 45
000 people there or something crazy
but it looks sort of like a small
college arena really
um
yeah i i think there will probably be
more lies than people at tonight's rally
let's put it that way and i think we can
we can sort of leave it at that
um
david congratulations on the baby so
happy for you says o g k b seeker who
has been a beta level member on youtube
for eight months i appreciate that thank
you
thank you also to eyes of the bluest
skies and punk on a bike for the twitch
prime subscriptions and i want to also
thank nathan de john
and adam johnson who just signed up at
my website joinedpakman.com you can use
the coupon code indict for a discount
always available is the coupon code
obama obama yeah that that's we that's a
steady that's a staple
of the live streams i think i would say
do we want to do a couple more
voicemails or do we want to listen to
what's going on at the rally
it's a 5 000 person venue someone is
saying okay
that's a pretty good that's good for
trump i guess i mean he'll never say
there's only 5 000 people probably say
more like 50. the host on the right has
a fly caller and a couch pattern jacket
did he think it was 1976 and not 1776 oh
i didn't even notice it
uh oh i see
yeah no this guy's got quite a look it's
a distinctive look
i mean quite frankly i'm more concerned
with the crazy things he says let's
listen a little bit love my country and
that's all that matters it's interesting
because all due in june we spent our
time in dc several times three weeks
straight we were going back there for
supreme court stuff there was nothing
but ukraine flags and pride flags up and
down pennsylvania avenue every business
had that's horrible isn't it that's
pretty much i think pandering to that
particular group saying that we support
you whether or not they do or not but
they're looking to as a marketing
standpoint so first you're signaling
this virtual signal so what i did uh
during july 4th is i said i hope that
every business in dc removed those flags
and put up the american flag as they
should taking a principled and patriotic
stand there as you guys can very easily
tell
they are really hitting the important
issues here on right side broadcasting
really really major stuff
let's see
a couple of other
voicemails oh
people have been asking whether whitney
has been calling in she took a break
from calling in and i believe she's back
so um i noticed on my trip to greece
that um
the
the greek people just like love italians
and also um english people like really
really really really really love english
people wow um
and
they seem to
feel like really rudely about americans
um but what i noticed is that um
like i don't feel like the affection
goes both ways when it comes to
um italy and greece ooh that's a dicey
topic that's a dicey topic then whitney
calling back again
i really see these women who think that
their husbands cheat on them but then
they stay with them
is it like cool like
maybe somebody like licked us and got
some poop in my mouth but it's like all
right as long as it doesn't happen again
i think i'm gonna get away from that
that's
that's a bit much i think for this show
today at least
uh
yeah let's
let's maybe let's maybe step away from
that a little bit
robert dalen says did i see the rogers
telecom outage in canada i did not that
is not something i saw
uh but
i am going to be in canada for a very
strong period of time next month and i'm
going to be counting on internet
so i hope they have it fixed by then
hopefully canada's not out of
out of internet for a very long period
of time that would that would be tragic
i want to say thank you to carlito odell
who just signed up at joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 67. guys
let's just we're two-thirds of the way
there
i say let's just finish it before trump
even comes out which i believe is
happening any moment
joinedpakman.com
coupon code indict
it's so cheap it's almost a crime not to
do it
and in fact i'm talking to the police
about whether we might be able to act on
that
i did get a haircut yes
it had been a very very long time in
fact i was even getting a mullet back
here
and uh
my hairdresser said with tears in her
eyes
she said you need a haircut and i said
that's why i'm here ma'am please let's
do it we've got to do it
and we did it took like four hours
because it was uh
it was it was crazy it was crazy
tax the church says christopher martin
god should have some skin in the game
wow
that's a that's a pretty major
declaration
i don't even know that i'm really
prepared to comment on that
um
thanks to lilika 566 for the twitch
prime subscription putting us at 68
that's 68 of the way to 100.
you know yeah it's it's different here
and of course if you come here in
january february march i was told that
the sun is only up for about five and a
half hours starting at around 10 to like
one ish two you know he was told it
would be very hard hard to have
dark and cold because it will be very
cold for those months yeah yeah you know
it's not cold right now right now it's
probably in the 60s i would think it's
kind of deceiving like when this is not
when this announcement is true the
sunset is 11 29 p.m tonight in anchorage
um i actually had a little bit of
experience with this uh as some of you
know i have family in northwestern spain
and let me see if i can even find this
map of europe
let's see here where the hell is this
map copy image link yeah there's this
really interesting thing in spain and i
hope i get the story correct so as you
can see here the left side of this so
let me orient you this is a map of
europe for people who may or may not
know the left side is west ish and the
right side is east ish okay
and um from the standpoint of time zones
it gets later and later as you go to the
right and if this part is known to most
people in the audience then i apologize
but i just want to make sure we're all
on the same page now as you can see
here is spain okay and italy is all the
way over here
now for political reasons
spain in the franco era decided we're
going to be in the same time zone as the
rest of europe
okay so
it's sort of a little weird because when
you look at how far west spain is
relative to italy you would be like well
shouldn't spain probably be in the same
time zone as the uk and ireland and
portugal and the answer is yes it should
so in general in the summer the sun sets
very late in spain because
they are sort of like one time zone over
from where they probably should be for
geographical reasons but then here's
like the extra thing okay
um
this northwestern part of spain this
area here
is like extra west so one of the places
that i have family and i'll go with some
frequency
is right up all the way over here and
they're almost like two time zones off
from where they should be and so you get
beautiful evenings where the sun it's
not not like bright sun but uh you have
light until like
10 40 maybe
or let's even see
what's the time uh the sunset right now
so right now it's 10 14. yeah so at like
10 45 you still have some light it's it
i loved it actually i loved it it was
you know it explains why people have
dinner so late there
uh
yeah no i it's not a problem for me i
mean yeah the sun comes up later but who
cares i'm i'm not typically up that
early so it's a great thing yeah who
cares i i'm not guys i'm not critic
people are acting like david they can be
in whatever time zone they want
i don't care
i'm just telling you what it is
weird reaction weird reaction
all right i want to say thank you
to carrie stevens
for signing up at joinedpakman.com new
member number 69
gifted memberships coming in from
stephanie cornwell
jason sickmeyer
who else do we have here another one
from stephanie cornwell
another one from simon reed thanks to
marshall bell
another one from stephanie cornwell
and uh thanks to oh and stephanie
cornwell again that's seven more putting
us at 76. really appreciate that very
very much appreciate that coupon code is
indict and i believe we will get there
do you think trump will trash bannon for
agreeing to talk to the j6 committee i
don't believe he will trash bannon
tonight no i don't think so
sir if the supreme court took away
abortion rights what's going to stop
them from forcing us citizens to wear
audio monitors to make sure we don't
utter words the gop do like
um i don't 100 understand but i don't
think that's gonna happen
david sir isn't trump just teaching the
presidential run without announcing so
he doesn't have to follow stricter
fundraising reporting rules that is a
specu that is uh that's been asserted
yeah it's been asserted
thanks to robert and catwoman
for the um
for the super chats very much appreciate
that
few other um few other voicemails coming
in here hey david uh it's nathaniel i'm
calling from long beach and i recently
just joined on your live stream thank
you uh i was wondering if since
sometimes you cover international news
if you've been talking about uh the
prime minister assassination that
happened on friday with shinzo abe yes
uh i've just found that to be very
interesting just because like there's
not a lot of other countries don't have
as many guns
as or a gun culture in the united states
a second one i don't know if you'll have
an answer to this one but when do you
think
younger people
that fall in line with more of what the
people want will eventually make it into
office and then finally give like people
what they want well they'll be a little
bit older but yet no i'll be covering
the shinzo abe assassination that's a
major major story i mean that's like if
bill clinton were to be killed
but even crazier because japan has so
relatively uh fewer fewer uh guns so of
course i will absolutely be talking
about that absolutely
uh let's see what else we got here sir
did you ever end up going to alaska it's
beautiful up there highly recommend no
i've still never been to alaska i ended
up going to miami instead and uh yeah it
was it was great but i want to make it
up to alaska
just gifted five more memberships to
apologize for and counteract my fellow
alaskans
that are maga cult kool-aid drinkers
well thank you stephanie i appreciate
that very much
yeah and then here's the the last gift
from stephanie cornwell that's number 77
and i also want to thank
i know is this name pronounced is it
joke joe kim
it's like joaquin but with an m
layman
signing up with the coupon code indict
number 78
uh i appreciate that very much
um
voicemail
yeah i just
sir
what is with the dude on the stream that
looks like a crazy version of ryan
reynolds thank you is that this guy
i don't i mean i don't totally see the
resemblance but i guess
it might be what's being referred to i
don't know
i it must be this guy
uh one more
hey david this is tony um i am calling i
can't tell you every
time i hear marjorie taylor green
and
lauren balbert and so many of these
right wingers
i think about the show
that i saw hate thy neighbor it's
something that you have to pay to see i
think it's only available and i don't
know amazon prime or something like that
but
um
you have to purchase it by the season
but there's a an episode
that is about white supremacy and white
nationalists and you know basically
nazis but they don't like to call
themselves nazis they're a little funny
about that um
but i just really feel like that's where
we're headed it would be a really good
show for you to watch if you haven't
seen it um
[Music]
okay sad to see but it's all about
things that are happening right in our
backyard sounds interesting i mean i'm
totally up for checking that out why not
why not
hey david i got a quick question i don't
know if you're even going to be able to
answer but
if the repercussions of this
hearing
or you know the justice that follows
afterwards
if that trump can no longer
go run for office
then is he still precluded that speaker
of the house campaign that we've talked
about before no he can still be speaker
of the house as far as i know in that
situation
jack clark says via super chat john
fetterman made his first public
appearance today at a volunteer meeting
he also has some fundraisers scheduled
later this month and launched a new ad
that's great to hear aft after the
stroke
there were questions as to how soon and
to what degree would fetterman get back
to the campaign trail great to see that
he is back all right welcome everyone if
you're just joining us we are about we
are moments away and from uh these
police officers getting you know kind of
wound up uh it seems it is imminent that
donald trump is going to appear and
speak they have them coming out from
like a backlit flag in alaska
everything about this very strange rumor
is trump may announce his 2024 candidacy
tonight we are here live on youtube
twitch and facebook i want to welcome
the 9 000 people watching on youtube and
the 1000 people watching on twitch i
actually have no idea how many people
are watching on facebook i should look
let's see hey to everybody on facebook
of course
uh a beautiful platform i guess it's
called meta now the kids call it meta
actually i think the kids just don't use
it to be totally frank
um
well i
i can't figure out how many people are
watching on facebook but welcome to
everybody watching on facebook as well
we have been listening to voicemails we
have been looking at clips of trump
supporters at the event we have been
looking at um
super chats and everything
and because at this point we are no
longer
you know mincing words i think is the
way i would put it
today's coupon code is indict it's a
trump rally and the coupon code is
indict and if i have to explain that to
you it's probably not the right coupon
code for you
this is may not even be the right
channel for i think my core audience
understands why the coupon code would be
indict
at a trump rally
and i would love
for you to sign up at joinpacman.com we
may be ready to hit a hundred listen to
these folks who just signed up
rachelle cortez is number 79
josh badis is number 80.
jim little is number 81 bill lawrence is
number 82. brian stewart is number 83
and frank olsouski is number 84. we
might be able
to breach 100
before trump even speaks which would be
an historic accomplishment
let's listen to the sounds and the
sights oh my god look at mike huckabee
um let's listen i'm just going to ask
you he's back here he can hear that
right now i think i i believe he's
arrived and i would i would imagine if
he's here he can hear that chance oh
yeah yeah and he gets excited about it
and like he'll actually go i want to go
out i want to go out i want to go out
like he's
i think he's here i i actually haven't
gotten an official word but
i haven't i haven't got that official
word either i'm assuming he is i think
he is because he's got to have meetings
before the rally sure you've uh absol of
course meetings
how could trump not show up and have
meetings
it is a cult i mean the degree to which
uh do we
do we really i mean eventually he'll
speak right like oh there's a word word
has been passed down
sir is here sir
sure are you sorry sir sir sir sure and
be speaking before a crowd of millions
of people in alaska incredible
absolutely incredible
david i sent you an email with regards
to my employer walgreens breaking state
wage laws they had changed policy
because of my work with the rhode island
department of labor okay very
interesting kratos aureon
orion or orion thank you
i mean to prevent people from uttering
word the gop don't like it was in a show
where they banned anything sexual or
dirty they monitors to prevent it
i haven't seen the show but that sounds
interesting
that sounds that sounds very interesting
a thank you to mzfrazzled
unhappy max twerkzilla and rhar
for the twitch prime subscriptions guys
that's 88
francois lambert
like bo bear lambert
just gifted a subscription which is
number 89 and sean schilling
just signed up
new member number 90.
guys i think we can do it
i will give away a free item from my
online store
to new member 95 and 100. if we can do
it okay whoever is number 95 i'll get
you a free item from my store hat
t-shirt hoodie whatever coffee mug
and number 100 okay two free items
coming up
robert glover is number 91.
okay who's gonna get the free stuff this
should be interesting
there may be a scramble
we could be seeing a scramble any second
sack of bonbons hassi and cradler
put us at 94. okay so next person will
be 95 you get a free item
and then number 100 also gets a free
item
let's see what happens and will it
happen before trump speaks
is the other question does the newborn
like mangoes either way congrats yeah my
one month old daughter likes mango and
pepperoni pizza and the pediatrician
said
no absolutely not
what do you think about gavin newsom for
president could he be the next bill
clinton of democrats i have extensive
gavin newsom coverage okay on
the
bonus show
from last week multiple bonus shows i
talk extensively about gavin newsom
extensively about gavin newsom
david sir can we hear trump
mispronouncing names i've got some of
them here
[Applause]
we've endorsed jp right jd mandel obama
i've had more investigations than jesse
james billy they could
yup oh i've even got trump
mispronouncing his own name then he went
donald trump yeah donald trump yep how
come he looks as big as steven seagal
these days i think the ryan reynolds
looking guy is the one with the blue
baseball cap on blue baseball cap i
don't even know on what channel that is
oh like right here oh okay this guy
interesting
i'll join if the prize is a clone of
willy well i don't have that
unfortunately
i was worried that the abe assassin
could be linked to a chinese or other
country's paramilitary this could be
similar to world war one's start does
not appear to be the case does not
appear to be the case all right guys
let's give away some stuff okay
new member number 95 is jordan clark
jordan you get a free item from my
online store please email
info
davidpakman.com to claim it
okay
next
brian crewman is number 96
and ara
ekmekian
is number 97.
uh okay
so again free item for number 100 steven
prugar
is number 98.
we're going to get it very soon here
emily aaron is number 99
and the free item goes to number 100
oh let me look at a super chat first
trump will be charged with felonies and
will not be able to run for any
political office ever again you know i
don't believe that that will happen
i hope that it does but i don't believe
that it will
it's just my opinion
and member number 100 using the coupon
code indict is brady gandy brady
congratulations
you can email info davidpakman.com to
claim your prize
we are oh wow
monge poutine i which i will be doing in
montreal very soon has gifted five
subscriptions
619 plaid mercuti mercutio head
hey on live colors atk loopy joey bag of
donuts
have all gotten twitch memberships
that's 109.
also want to say thanks to lisa bradley
man i actually don't know that i can
keep up with all of these
jason sickmeyer
jeff adler
scott labrie
stephanie cornwell
juan
lawrence quartowitz
and terry schwerin sorry nope tiffany
mclay oh my god i can't even give up
david torres that's 10 that puts us at
119. folks it's happening toe says
living in central texas you can't escape
the trump fascists thanks for being a
breath of sanity super congrats on the
baby thank you toe
i appreciate that very much
uh we are
you have not missed the rally we're
expecting trump any moment
dirty curtain just grabbed the twitch
prime subscription with the message
uh oh hold on i did have a couple other
things to go over
uh
oh yeah so i guess i guess mehmet oz has
did a did a campaign ad and it's just
like really noisy
first it was aoc and dorsey john
fetterman next came elizabeth warren
veteran we already know he has bernie
sanders support the more extreme
radicals that are left have made their
choice clear
john fetterman fits right in with their
father this is terrible audio production
left agenda like aoc's green new deal
and warren's reckless spending programs
which by the way is what got us into
this inflation crisis
when america's most extreme liberals are
endorsing jon fetterman tells you
everything you need to know about what
kind of senator he would be pennsylvania
deserves better is this an industrial
laundry it reminds me from the chicken
the chicken laundry
in breaking bad those are the vibes i'm
getting here also this is a very strange
angle where mehmet oz looks like he's
5'4
but like he has a humongous head just
everything about this is produced
horribly
horribly horribly hey this is really
interesting and i don't know how much
time i'm going to have for this because
the event might start
so
i have i don't i haven't seen anything
from this rising show
for
it feels like years and years
but i've been told i've seen a couple of
clips that people
showed me on stream
uh of this woman in the middle kim
iverson who is whacked i mean whacked
out of her gourd
um
anti-vac stuff i think she spoke at like
the anti-vaxx rally
completely cuckoo for cocoa buffs i mean
just off
unhinged and i guess that this new host
on the left whose name i also don't know
i guess she kind of called out these
other two let's check this out it was
what elliot page's name was before i
would like i guess we should not say it
because maybe that would violate some
politicians
that's something crazy why is it i don't
understand why is it why is that any
creation and if people change their name
call me this call me this i prefer to be
called right
not even
to not even be allowed to acknowledge
that you used to have a different name
what do you need to be able to
acknowledge that for what how are you
suffering where's your home what's your
passion that person lived as a different
person for a long time decades and so to
say that suddenly we all have to pretend
like those decades didn't exist and that
that person wasn't that person for those
decades you're not going to pretend okay
the new the new host this woman on the
left
this is ola yemi olurin yeah and i i
like her quite a bit based on what she
does here just can't i understand i just
can't say it out loud no you can't right
why are we pretending like that is
what's happening here it's very simple
this person there it says a trans man
now elliot page that is their name that
is the name
i said they're done
exactly absolutely their dead name is
their dead name they don't go by that
anymore they find it dehumanizing or
diminishing to their personnel to be
called that and that is what it is it's
not uncommon people change their names
all the time and we use the different
names that they would that they go by
right
if somebody goes well who's that i go oh
they used to be x i would fill them in
and you can't do that on social media
because of this policy did you get
banned from calling prince prince even
after he changed his name to a symbol i
mean that's the same god
we are comparing apples and vegetables
because we literally because this is a
trans person we've explained this the
name the dead name reflects a person and
identity they do not recognize they do
not recognize they find it uh uh
psychologically harmful to be seen and
that way they moved on
i mean maybe
prince
prince really is actually the filter
through which we should think of all
trans rights uh prince
being called all rights
listen go ahead go ahead go forth go for
smartly go i think it's i think it's a
really weird for especially for a for a
a famous person what happened to this
show like a a a person of some notable
public significance to be disforming
suave
disallowed from talking about some
public and no we're
listen for the dad name to trend for
something to trend people have to use be
using it massively it has to be being
discussed let's not act like we don't
know where that comes from if we know
that this is now a trans a trans person
they go by elliott page and there are a
large amount of people calling them by
their dead name so much so that it
trends there is a deliberacy in there
meant to offend this person because you
know they do not go by that anymore i
don't know what is this
if anyone was continuing to use it and
not using the new name just to be you
know provocative or mean spirited right
i mean i i used i would use the name the
person wants to use now and i would
recognize their gender identity now
but i i i will i i do not think we
should be for for a public person for
someone who is well known to the people
man talk about belaboring huh for like
for sake of clarity or for sake of
biography to acknowledge that they used
to have a different name you could just
sound crazy to say that well you see how
but do you see how we we sat here and we
had this whole discussion we
acknowledged that they used to have a
different name we acknowledged that they
had this life before that but we never
called them the the name well no it's
tip toeing around
but you're not allowed we have the whole
conversation yes and what is the problem
with that you're not allowed to call
somebody by your name but they don't go
by anymore
guys it's crazy
how can we even have like a reasonable
world
it's crazy and we need kim iverson and
robbie suave to explain it to us be not
allowed to say what a person was for a
decade
we would just
move over to that and be like well he we
got to respect him
oh my god that's like an editorialized
that's not a name oh my god these people
y'all continuously watching y'all are
clearly invested and pretending like
y'all don't understand the significance
no i understand it i don't know so go
ahead go ahead i've already explained it
all right well we've had we've had this
one out so wow like
do you think these people get paid for
doing this the two on the right
it is shocking to me what's going on
here
wow
also this concept of being allowed is an
interesting
i don't even know that i want to get
into that right now but okay i've got
one other thing here for you guys
this is okay jordan peterson thinks the
russian invasion of ukraine is a civil
war with the west over wokeness
oh boy
is he defending the invasion here
on
religious issues and then
cultural issues
pertaining mostly now to the culture war
that we seem to be engulfed in i would
say not only in the west but in the rest
of the world and which has actually
broken out into a real war because i
believe that the war between russia and
ukraine or really between russia and the
west rest of the west is a
civil war not just
what would you call it post-soviet
territorial expansion on the part of the
russians
what values do you think there are stake
there like russia against the west what
do you think it's fighting it's just is
it
liberal values against conservative or
is it something more no it's complicated
it's more complicated than liberal
against conservative
well i think the foreign policy expert
psychologist jordan peterson the
russians
are
or
yes
i think putin has
weaponized a certain degree of anti-woke
sentiment among russians
and
some of that
anti-doctrine let's say which is more
conservative he may also believe but
minimally he's managed to use it very
effectively on the propaganda front
and uh
man i don't know if these bad takes are
coming because peterson stopped eating
only meat or because he's eating only
meat i really am unsure what the cause
of it is but it's wacky
wacky wacky wacky and that's a joke okay
he's he's still welcome on my show
anytime i would of course be completely
respectful to him just like the last
time he was on we're being hyperbolic
we're being entertaining but i would
respect him as a person if he came on
just so you know because he now he might
be like well look you you said uh you
know what he's welcome anytime on the
show
anytime
okay uh super chats could you give us a
rundown of garden veggies my wife and i
are growing cabbage lettuce bok choy
peppers carrot sunflowers trump favorite
potatoes tomatoes love the show honestly
right now i don't even know what i have
i i've i've like been away
so much
um and especially with the baby
now i'm not even like i haven't watered
for so long
i've got fennel
snap peas
beets two types of tomatoes
three types of hot peppers
purple cabbage
romaine lettuce
um
celery it means like celery is such a
boring vegetable but it it's sort of
going well the the celery is actually
growing pretty well
um
i think that's it yeah i mean that's a
bunch of stuff it's a bunch of stuff
so for context rhode island is one of
the few states that offer time and a
half on sundays and holidays i've been
emailing the department of labor for
months with proof of that my co-workers
are happy now they owe us back pay well
done kratos well done
very very good good work
thanks to brutal and uh thanks to brutal
for the twitch prime subscription you're
number 121 today
website uh social media
on uh twitter and instagram it's
christina
okay
i also want to say thanks to people
signing up on the website and there are
a lot of them thanks to tony bogle
aaron archer
violet desantis
star stern
elise capitula
these are website memberships samantha
horton is a new member donna divincenzo
is a new member
and a gift from td miller that's eight
putting us at 129.
really appreciate that and appreciate
everybody who's been signing up let me
make sure i didn't miss anybody
uh no i didn't the coupon code is indict
the coupon code is working it's a
beautiful coupon code
it really is
let's check in on a couple of voicemails
that have been uh delivered
do you think trump will talk about
windmills causing cancer on this rally
oh that's a good question
that's a good question supposing we hit
the body with a tremendous uh very
powerful light the noise causes cancer
right yep i don't know if trump will
viciously attack windmills today
but he often does
so i certainly would not
put it past him let's see over on
newsmax's coverage what's going on well
you know that just tells you about this
great country
and first and thank you for being so
open and honest about your story and
sharing that because i think that you
know there are young women out there who
are faced with you know the decision and
they need to you know get that counsel
be it from a pastor or someone are they
doing anti-abortion propaganda on
newsmax now it seems like they are
it's very very strange very very strange
all right we are moments away
from what could be one of the most
momentous trump rallies in a while
rumor has it he may announce his 2024
run
uh
but he may not i don't know
i don't know
um
we will all know very soon that's that's
absolutely for sure let's listen to
another voicemail or two here's one from
the eggman
hey dave
chipolone means giant onion
shalom no no no what are the what's the
name of those little onions
chipollini
cipollini onion
chipolini yeah so you've got your
chipolini onions and then you've got pat
sipoloni who was trump's white house
counsel two different two different
elements
you cook with one of them you subpoena
the other
uh sometimes they're called pearl onions
i think that's true
why is everyone standing now or
real quick i think president trump is
very close to coming out here any moment
here gentlemen and we see the cameras
are up and we just want to take a moment
here as uh
okay uh there he is
that's the uh that's the guy then he
went donald trump yeah donald trump okay
so a very very exciting day here
taking the stage to a very excited crowd
in anchorage alaska everybody
yeah
um in the meantime
in the meantime thanks to aftondes and
try kill eric new members number 130 and
131
super chat's coming in where do you draw
the line for giving guests this platform
to spew damaging rhetoric great question
jeff i've answered it many many times uh
my basic standard is
are the ideas of the radical guest
getting enough attention that they are
worth refuting to prevent them from
spreading and
can i
be adequately prepared to responsibly
platform the bad ideas and make an
attempt to either refute them or expose
them as stupid or misguided that's my
test so you know i get all these crazy
conspiracy emails david i figured out
that you know light bulbs can be used to
uh
you know cure covid and i want to be
interviewed it's an insane radical idea
but
nobody's really following it so it's not
worth refuting
along other lines
if it's an area that i am just not
well enough equipped to do the
refutation i will also pass but if i can
responsibly platform
uh radical ideas
i will do so and i will attempt to
refute the bad ideas that's basically my
standard
i want to say thank you to chris
tartaglia
number 132 today
i appreciate that
what happened to jimmy from philly i
almost miss his screens no idea
no idea
let's listen
let's see how the audio is over here
[Applause]
okay how many people will trump claim
are at the rally
i'm gonna take a five now that trump's
here refill my water and i'll be back
well i want to thank you and i want to
say a very big hello anchorage hello
[Applause]
and i'm thrilled to
be here with the very proud hard-working
patriots of the great and very beautiful
i'm flying over that
it is very beautiful state of alaska
[Applause]
i've heard for years there's no place
more beautiful and i agree i just saw
some things that you don't see in normal
places i'll tell you and this is not a
normal place when you have a lousy
senator like burkowski
but we're gonna do something about that
we're gonna do that's why
and as you know i'm here for two reasons
to support great candidates and to
fulfill my promise to alaska
that i was going to come here you know
that right
oh my god
you voted for me twice and i wanted a
landslide both times and
now i'm voting for you that's why i'm
here i'm voting for you
and also as you probably read or heard
my grandfather spent a little time in
alaska you know about that
and he loved it actually
four months from now the people of this
state are going to re-elect your
terrific governor mike dunleavy
a good man
i've been with him and he's been with me
from the beginning and you're going to
fire your rhino senator she's worse than
a rhino lisa murkowski
she is the worst
i rate her number one band and we have a
couple of real bad ones but she's by far
the worst
we'll go over that you want to go over
that we'll go over that in a little
while
but you're going to elect a wonderful
woman a conservative warrior
kelly chewbacca
[Applause]
i think they like you kelly
they like you
and you're going to send the great
legendary
sarah palin to the u.s house of
representatives
incredible woman you know uh
just quickly on sarah early on 2015
actually and i was running and people
didn't really know too much about me
other than business stuff and
i said let's run because we got to
straighten out the country we did a hell
of a job by the way
but
but sarah was hot as a pistol and
everybody wanted her and
that they just wanted that endorsement
and she was with somebody else
and i figured that was that but that's
all right but
sarah came out of nowhere and she said
the one i like best is a guy named
donald trump
so sarah i'm here to say
i like you best i know your opponents
and i like you way better
you're great sarah and i appreciate it
and i won't forget
i won't forget we're going to end crazy
nancy pelosi's political career once and
for all
you could take the five worst presidents
in american history and then put them
all together mix them all up
and they would not have done the
incredible damage that joe biden has
done to our country in less than
two short years two years
the contrast between the trump
administration's amazing success and
even the other side says i gotta hand it
and as you know last week we had a lot
of success in many ways in a place
called the supreme court you saw what
happened
ronald reagan forden tried to do it and
everybody did but
four things came down last week on guns
on religious liberty on the environment
and
roe
v wade
that was a big win
they've been trying on all of that but
they've been trying for many many
decades
and we got it done the contrast between
the trump administration's amazing
success and joe biden's breathtaking
failure could not be more stark
so let's look at the facts
i got gasoline down to
[Music]
[Applause]
a
1.87
and they have it at
five six seven and even eight dollars a
gallon and it's going high
i gave you the largest tax cuts and
regulation cuts in american history
the radical democrats are working like
hell to impose the largest tax hike by
far in american history you do know
they're looking to raise your taxes by a
lot to pay for the green new deal
[Music]
you know based on the green new deal
remember they started at 12 years you
only have about seven years left
i don't think anybody is too worried
right you could worry about nuclear
warming but you can't worry about the
global warming the global warming they
said the other day i heard somebody that
the oceans are going to rise 1 8 of an
inch over the next 300 years we have
bigger problems than that
we'll have a little bit more beachfront
property that's not the worst thing in
the world
and they're working feverishly to pile
on more regulations at levels never seen
before
under the trump administration we had
the greatest economy in the history of
the world with no inflation
and before the plague came in from china
we had numbers that nobody's ever seen
then we did a hell of a job never got
credit for that more people died under
biden you saw that
and the job we did
with kovador as some people call it to
be more accurate the china virus
but we did so much in terms of
therapeutics and a word that i'm not
allowed to mention but i'm still proud
of that word
because we did it we did that
we did that in nine months and it was
supposed to take five years to 12 years
nobody else could have done it but i'm
not mentioning it in front of my people
but
someday we're going to have to all sit
down and have a little talk but you know
what we did a hell of a job biden
created the worst inflation in 40 years
and going higher it's going much higher
which is costing families near the
nearly think of this one
six thousand
seven hundred and fifty nine dollars a
year
bigger than any taxi increase ever
proposed by anybody that's
numbers like that are unthinkable in
terms of a tax increase but that's what
you're paying your price for inflation
and we had no inflation we had it down
so good and you know what caused the
inflation the energy when the energy
started rocketing up everything else
went up we created seven million new
jobs we had a record
164 million people working far more than
now we achieved the largest poverty
reduction in 50 years we lifted seven
million people off of food stamps and we
lifted 10 million people off welfare 10
million people
[Applause]
under biden there are still four million
people who have not returned to the
labor force real wages are just
absolutely collapsing especially when
you add inflation nobody's ever seen
anything like it and the misery index
did you ever hear the misery index it's
real
is soaring to heights that we've never
seen before the misery index that
doesn't sound too good
i rebuilt our military including nuclear
capability and the creation of space
force
and in your case i can say it much of it
has come to a place called alaska did
you ever hear that
much of it much of that military has
come to alaska
they surrendered our strength and our
effort and all of the blood sweat and
tears
what they did in afghanistan it was the
greatest humiliation
in the history of our country
and remember i got it down i wanted out
we would have gotten out with strength
and dignity would have taken the
military outlast not first
not one soldier was killed
in the last 18 months in afghanistan i
met with
through the telephone a couple of times
abdul the leader of the taliban
and the fake news is saying why did you
speak to the leader of the taliban i say
who else am i going to speak with
that's the one and i said abdul don't do
it don't do it they were killing a lot
of our people the snipers i said don't
do it abdul don't do it it's much
tougher than that but i don't want to do
it now
i'm not in the mood to do it now because
every time i think of this subject he
gets sick to your stomach
but you know what we didn't lose one
soldier in 18 months and then we
withdrew and we lost a lot of soldiers
13 but it's 13 and they never talk about
those soldiers that have been
horrifically wounded
just uh incredibly with the arms and the
legs and everything else we created
think of it that afghanistan thing as
bad as they were doing on the border and
there's never been a country in my
opinion any country third world fourth
world no country's ever done worse on
the border than we've done but when the
afghanistan thing happened that was the
end that was the biggest embarrassment
in the history of our country
think of it 13 dead many wounded
85 billion dollars of the finest
military equipment in the world left
behind
[Applause]
you know they're now they are now the
largest arms dealer in the world did you
know that
i read the other day that the largest
arms because they're selling it they
don't need 700 000 rifles and guns so
they're selling a lot of them
71 000 trucks and vehicles you know what
there's not a
there is not a car company in the united
states that has any inventory of 70 000
bicycles
automobiles
these are 70 000 many of them are
armor-plated the most expensive things
you've ever seen
70 000 trucks and vehicles we left
behind
and think of that though 700 000
rifles how many lies have i missed
oculus the best
night night vision they didn't fight in
the night because they can't see now
they can fight at night better than what
we have because they have the brand new
version
airplanes tanks helicopters they gave
one to russia
they gave one to china because they
haven't been able to catch us on
helicopters but now they're taking it
apart and they'll be able to do it also
that was the worst humiliation we've
ever had we created the safest border
just two years ago
in u.s history
[Applause]
we had the safest border
now we have the worst we ended catch and
release we deported record numbers
thousands and thousands of illegal alien
gang members we got them out
i don't think i've ever seen this strong
a presence for uh blacks for trump at
these events than and it's in alaska no
less two and a half years of
horrible litigation all inspired by the
democrats many of them in congress we
won them all 11 different cases we won
them all
and we started and we did a great job
with that that's one of the reasons our
numbers were so low plus mexico gave us
28 000 soldiers for nothing you know why
they gave us the soldiers because they
said if you don't we're going to tear
off all of your product coming into the
united states and they said we would
love to give you 28 000 free soldiers
we would love mr president to give you
would you like some more we'll give you
some more i said i don't think we can
fit anymore
we had 28 000
soldiers mexican soldiers and they were
great and the president's a great guy he
really is he's a great guy a little
different persuasion he's a socialist
but he's a great guy
but he was very nice and we set records
like nobody's ever seen nobody can even
believe our numbers three weeks was
all it was taken to finish that extra
section of the world they didn't want to
do it not only didn't they do it they
took the pieces away so that texas and
arizona couldn't use them
the border was the best and safest in
u.s recorded history and they have is
any of this true
now
you have the worst border in history
biden and the radical left
have turned calm into chaos
competence into incompetence stability
into anarchy
prosperity into poverty
and security into catastrophe and
instead of energy independence you know
we were energy independent a year and a
half ago
[Applause]
imagine flying all the way to alaska for
a completely absurd speech and then your
mic has feedback the entire rally
for energy you see what they're doing
he's going to saudi arabia to ask for
oil
he didn't like saudi arabia i did i
always liked him but he didn't like him
now he's going there and he's asking for
oil please give us energy how about last
week
thousands of barrels
of oil you know where it's going to
china
and it comes out of these strategic
reserves
that i built up 75 million barrels of
oil we put in there at low numbers too
when it was nice and low
the election was rigged in seoul and now
our country is being systematically
destroyed
yesterday we got big news out of the
great state of wisconsin did you see it
the wisconsin supreme court ruled that
widespread use of ballot drop boxes i
call them
unlock boxes because they unlock them
no more dropbox the dropbox isn't
illegal
i said illegal
[Applause]
so they said it was illegal
so what does that mean i know what that
means you all know what that means how
about some of these boxes come in 100
votes for biden none from top done we
got they couldn't even give me
oh god
uh oh
all right let's switch over here done we
got they couldn't even give me one
that's why they're called unlock boxes
just as i've said all along
the use of these unmanned unsecured drop
boxes was never authorized by the state
legislature but partisan radical
democrat officials simply did it anyway
they just put these boxes all over the
place and then they dumped them
in other words they systematically
violated the law
to rig the 2020 presidential election so
now in alaska we didn't have to worry
about it because we won
we won by so much you know
and what happened
dumps
we didn't worry about it didn't we
i ran twice i won twice i did much
better the second time than i did the
first believe it or not
getting many many millions more votes
than we did in 2016
and likewise getting more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our
country by far
[Applause]
and now with the approval of the great
people of alaska we may have to do it
again
[Music]
it's funny when he says more votes than
any sitting president it's like well
when you consider the population of the
u.s has been growing and growing and
growing
it would make sense that over time
candidates would set records for getting
the most votes and biden got like 8
million more
[Applause]
one of the most urgent tasks for the
republican party this november because
you're gonna have you have the votes
you're gonna win
you're gonna win
but you have to make sure that you watch
the voting and the ballot counting
because
kelly
and sarah
your governor they're going to win but
you got to watch the ballot county the
democrats have proven
unfortunately that the vote counter is
far more important than the candidate
does that make sense to you
you know that's an old expression used
by a
a very powerful man i won't even give
you his name because we don't need that
name thrown out they'll say trump
admires him no i don't admire him but he
said the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate was that
mussolini when we win a top priority for
the republican congress must be to end
the nightmare joe biden has created on
our southern border
every day the radical left's open
borders policies are getting innocent
americans killed
a few months ago an illegal alien in
florida was charged with violently
beating to death a 74 year old woman
this reminds me of the this incident
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
yeah they found her in a shallow grave
last year an illegal alien in chicago
walked into his neighborhood home and
executed a
person at point blank range while his
family was nearby and watching
and just this week in richmond virginia
two illegal aliens were arrested for a
plot to conduct a brutal mass shooting
at a fourth of july celebration and you
saw what happened on the fourth of july
with the other maniac yeah the trump the
radical democrats have turned our
country into one giant sanctuary for
dangerous criminal aliens
in the republican party we believe our
country should be a sanctuary for law
abiding citizens who love america like
we do
like we do
as we restore the rule of law in our
borders we must also restore law and
order to our streets
all democrat run you know that it's one
thing they have in common democrat run
under joe biden last year
murders hit the highest rate in 25 years
and probably much more than that they
don't go back any further and this year
it's going much much higher we're in a
clip that nobody's ever even imagined
before
under a republican congress we should
pass emergency funding to hire thousands
more police officers we love our police
[Applause]
i just met some of your police officers
backstage we took pictures with them
they are the best looking human beings i
hate to say it i've ever seen they look
like could the audio be any worse
they look like tom cruise only better
[Applause]
but we want thousands more police
officers and communities nationwide to
put violent criminals behind bars and
keep them behind bars and send them the
hell out of our country and back to
their country when necessary
and we're going to tell our politicians
to leave our police alone let them do
their job give them back their respect
they know what to do we have to allow
them to do it
[Applause]
right
instead of targeting republicans
conservatives christians and patriotic
parents
the biden administration should try
going in and dismantling the street
gangs and deadly cartels that are
occupying our beautiful cities
and instead of taking guns away from
law-abiding americans we should try
taking them away from violent felons and
career criminals
[Applause]
and enforcing existing federal statutes
to get them in jail or bring them back
where they belong in their own country
get them the hell out of here and have
them
have them be looked at very carefully we
don't want them back
you know we had a very hard they had a
very hard time coming back into our
country we got them out you know the
problem was that you'd have the gangs
right you'd have all these horrible
gangs that come from in some cases
mexico but guatemala do we know why
trump's right eye is swollen almost
completely shut
counted last week of people that came
illegally 141 countries
but we couldn't bring them back to those
countries they wouldn't take them this
was under obama
you couldn't bring them back they
wouldn't take it
so
so border patrol who are phenomenal
people and i saw these guys these are
phenomenal brave incredible people
but they were told you can't bring them
back because the countries wouldn't take
them
the countries wouldn't take them so they
don't want the gang members back they
don't like people that
kill people so right yep uh super chat
and others correctly pointing out this
particular guy here in the white shirt
that says blacks for trump he travels to
the rallies he's been at rallies all
over the country alaska's uh you know
alaska's not that close and we'd have to
fly it back so i said how much do we pay
those countries the three primary
countries right how much do we pay them
and they said about 750 million dollars
a year i say inform them that we are
stopping payment no more payments
by the way they've been working on this
problem for 10 years this one took me
about three minutes to think out
i said inform them we're not making any
more payments because they're not
treating us with respect which now
they're really nobody's treating us with
respect
and the next day i got a call from all
three presidents of those countries and
they basically said the same thing they
said sir you've stopped payment
because you're not treating our country
with respect you're not taking in your
gang members that left your country
probably you push them out of your
country into the united states to be
more exact i said if you don't take them
back we're not going to make the payment
but sir why didn't you call me we'd be
honored to serve
we would love to have ms 13 back they're
such wonderful people please please sir
send ms-13 back into our country we love
them very much
and from that point on we had no problem
yeah people asking how long this might
go with how far alaska is i think
trump's going to try to get his money's
worth and he might he might go a very
long time it's ridiculous
so they were getting like 750 million
and i heard the other day that biden
wants to make it four billion dollars
they said no you make it less than more
so i think they're going to pay 4
billion or something like that to these
countries so you're going to have a lot
of rich
presidents dictators and others
it's a it's so just it's so stupid what
we're doing in our country is so stupid
if you want to make our country safe for
violent criminals vote for the radical
crazy democrats if you want to make it
safe for your family your children and
for law abiding americans you must vote
republican and do it quickly and get
murkowski out of here because she's not
a republican civil war
[Applause]
the country doesn't win anymore
we don't win with our military with
education with trade with anything
although i won i knocked out isis we got
a hundred percent of isis god
remember al-baghdadi the founder of isis
how are you al baghdadi he's not around
any longer they've been looking for him
for 20 years
no isis is 100
we have great military we have
phenomenal military
[Applause]
remember general raisin kane did every
anybody ever hear that story general
kane anybody know general kane you know
not the television generals they're not
the good ones they're terrible
but the generals that really fight
general razon kane i went to iraq
and i wanted to get rid of isis and i
couldn't understand because a couple of
our television generals said it was
going to take anywhere from two to three
years i said you mean we have the most
powerful
military in the world and i was
rebuilding it at a level that they've
never seen before and why would it take
three years to do this this should go
quickly they said sir it'll take three
years
i said i don't think so that was general
mattis he said it will take three years
and i said i don't think so we're
spending all this time so i went to iraq
with the first lady and i said first
lady i think these guys know how to
fight we landed but before we landed i
don't know we're flying in air force one
they landed that's crazy that they went
there and landed and they said uh sir
could you please close your shades i
said i'm president you should close them
but i'll do it don't worry
there's a lot of shades in there you
know you'll be
and then they said sir we're going to be
uh
turning off the lights on the planet
i said what do you mean it's going to be
dark in the plane you won't be able to
see it all we won't have any light
i say that's not good why are you doing
that because we're flying into iraq
now we've been there for 20 years we
can't even land a presidential plane
there right we're flying into a wreck
it's dark
and i love these pilots these are the
best pilots in the world you know when
you fly air force one you got to be like
seriously good if you're looking for a
pilot right and you're willing to pay a
ridiculously high price if you have a
private plane like trump he could
recommend some pilots it's like a
pyramid right like the golfers you know
you get the guys these guys are good
so i go up and i want to watch if i see
on that plane you actually go up you
have to go up a floor
and i want to watch uh i want to watch
the landing
so i go up and i sit down two handsome
people and places loaded with these
fantastic like movie stars everyone's a
movie star and they say how are you sir
i say how we doing good we're landing in
10 minutes sir
i said this plane is so dark i can't see
anything they don't even have the
controls practically and like like
dimmed
and i'm going on five six seven minutes
and then i hear the
speaker it's from a computer the voice
of a computer only a pilot would know
it goes
one thousand
that means a thousand feet wow and it
goes
900 800
700 and i'm saying hey uh captain i
don't see any airport in front of us you
know we're
we're coming in at like 400 miles an
hour going very fast
i said why are we going so fast you know
the reason right it's harder
the faster you go the harder it is
so i say captain no where's the airport
sir no problem
i'm saying
all right is trump's brain falling out
right now
four hundred
three hundred
[Music]
two hundred and i'm saying oh
and i have these guys they're cool as a
cucumber i said captain you said we're
all right yes sir it's right ahead
there's no light
and we end up landing like perfect
like perfect it's like genius okay
and i go oh my god
he really has a way with words and just
weaves together these stories which such
vivid imagery and language
we made it ron
it's just like you made it all the time
with a
slap shot
but we
we landed i said great job captain there
was no problem yeah but i never i really
feel like i'm there yeah as he tells it
that's how good they are though it's
incredible it's brilliant so we landed
we the doors open and there's a general
waiting outside with another general and
another general and a staff sergeant or
a drill sergeant this guy you had to see
this guy with a crew cut i'm gonna have
my hair cut like that if i could thicken
it up a little bit
this guy's like a flat you could eat
dinner on the top of his hair
this guy's the best
all of them i don't know where did they
get these people it's like this crowd
look at this crowd everyone's good
looking
do they have any bad looking people in
alaska it's okay i guarantee you there
will be people who leave this and go man
trump's such a good speaker that was
amazing i are in history this guy this
is does anybody ever buy do you have to
be the i want you to do all of my head
buying
i could multiply it times 10 for the
same price
no but so we land and the door opens and
i walked down and they had these two
generals and the sergeant and what was
the point of this because everybody is
great
and we landed this incredible airport
that we took you know billions and
billions to build years ago
and i go in and i said would you like to
go to sleep i said no thanks let's go
let's go to work i'd rather not sleep
other people sleep i don't sleep
so we go in
and i said what's your name he said cain
sir my name's kane
i said that's a nice name what's your
first name raisin
i said wait a minute let's get this
straight sarah i said this
so
your name is kane but your first name is
raisin so your name is raisin kane
yes sir and he didn't say like a wise
guy you know he just didn't know what it
was either why was i questioning it
i said your name is raising kane i think
i'm gonna like you a lot
that's what i want i want a guy i want a
raisin cane right
so it's got to be high as a kite right i
mean what other explanation is there
here and or it's satire how long would
it take you
to knock out isis because general mattis
and some of the others are saying three
years
three years a long time
he said we can do it in
three weeks or maybe less
[Applause]
i said what
i said
i said raisin tell me that again
three weeks and we'll have time left
over sir
i said how would you do it in three
weeks well
i never liked what they did sir i said
why didn't you tell them
said that's not our job i'm a soldier
sir when they come in they tell us what
to do we do it we don't tell this is an
endless story i mean it just it's
meandering it goes nowhere you're right
you know
i couldn't understand it but not that
much
i said
you didn't want to get into like an
argument i would have had an argument
that i would have never been a general i
guess right
but i said so uh what would you do
different well sir we only attacked them
from this base and this base is very
very far away from where they are so by
the time we got our airplanes over there
we have to bring them back because they
get low on fuel we could only be in
fight for a very short period of time
sir i'd attack them from seven different
locations
we have bases all over
smaller than this some of them are
portable he called them portable bases
or something like that
i said so what would you do sir i'd hit
him on the left i'd hit him on the right
i'd hit him in the [ __ ] center sir
oh man
oh
edgy
edgy
[Applause]
[Applause]
man remember when trump swore at the
rally that was so great
but sir it hit him hard i'd hit him
really hard i'd hit him from all over
and we have a lot of planes sir we have
all these bases we could take off but
they only wanted to use this one this is
the furthest away and it was not good
not good said why didn't they use the
other bases politically correct they
didn't want to offend other countries
can you believe this can you believe
this
and he was being respectful and nice to
the people that he reported political
correctness was why they didn't use the
bases for so long 21 years
21 years it was enough the endless wars
so i said so generally you can do it in
three weeks i think less sir
i said
i'm going back to washington i'll give
you a call so i called him up i said
general are you sure you can do it
like that absolutely sir it'll be over
very quickly
i said go to it general go to it
and
genius huh
and in a very very short period of time
that was the end of isis 100 do you
remember i knocked out 98 i said all
right let's bring them home i want to
bring our people back home they don't
even want us over there why is isn't
iran fighting isis why isn't russia
fighting isis why aren't all these other
countries over there syria why aren't
they why are we the ones doing it and
they were enemies of them they hated
them more than we do
so why are we always doing it like with
ukraine we put up 60 billion dollars and
europe put up five
six
okay
[Music]
we are just
we're led by fools we're live by force
we had it going so good
but it was done
and then i got a call
sir give me the final order what does
that mean
i said there's a lot of them in a
certain area they all got together
i said uh we're gonna
we're gonna
do something about that they said we
gotta go after them sir get them knock
them out just tell us when we'll knock
them out in a matter of minutes right
these are human beings i mean
would they like to surrender you know i
say
he said sir they don't know what the
word surrender means i said these are
human beings he goes no sir they're
animals these are animals these aren't
human beings these are animals sir
i said look you know i mean i did nicely
in the real estate business i'm saying
now i gotta do this
and it's a hard thing to give an order
like that he wanted that order
and i said why don't you fly the planes
back and forth over him all over the
place scare the [ __ ] out of him he said
he said sir that's not going to have any
impact they don't scare so easy
so i said look give it three days by the
way the question was whether he prefers
uh breast or thigh when he has chicken
sir just give us the order it didn't
work did it no it didn't work sir
i said go ahead and do it we knocked out
100
of isis in a period of
and then we took out
right
we took out the leader of isis who was
trying to form it again remember you'd
always see the picture of this guy with
a fan behind them right they were
looking for him for 20 years
but we knocked him out remember conan
the dog conan became a bigger hero than
me do you know that conan and this is
okay conan got more credit for that than
i did they treated him like a dog
i didn't get credit for anything
except with the people i get credit
because they understand it
would it shock you to know the whole
story was on the prompter and then
salamani who's the father of the
roadside bomb who killed so many people
and maimed whenever you see somebody
walking around with
no legs a soldier no arms
blown to pieces that's salamani 90 of it
was salamani more than that
from iran knocked him out
al baghdadi salamani
[Applause]
and we were respected i want to tell you
when i told you i spoke with abdul
he was calling me your excellency yes
your excellency don't you say don't do
it again
but why your excellency do you send me a
picture of my house why
you imagine if you see someone walking
around with no legs it was probably
solamani what
you have some
critically important elections coming up
starting with the primaries of
august 16th so by the way i do want to
thank our soldiers because we have the
greatest in the world okay
i didn't want to give you a long story
but you know
every once in a while because you see we
look like fools all over the world with
the afghan
you know we we would have left but we
would have also
we want to we would have kept our big
airfields are people leaving bagram
it's one hour away from where china
makes their nuclear weapons we gave it
up billions and billions of dollars it
cost many years before billions longest
air runways most powerful runways they
can handle anything i think they're
eight feet thick of
concrete and steel
we gave it up and now i believe china is
occupying it can you even believe this
though they gave that up
so it's a very big embarrassment our
country has never been like this we've
never been so disrespected
we're being left at all over the world
and i wish i didn't have to say that i
wish
i wouldn't even be up here i wish i wish
we had a country that was respected and
doing great
because i don't get any thrill in saying
what i'm saying but everybody knows it
we have the lowest approval rating in
history
we are the least respected we've ever
been the opposite is actually true
and pay our respects to prime minister
abi because he is uh he was a great man
he was a great man
he had a great relationship with him
he would have been our friend
if we needed him
he was a great man
this is your precious chance to dump the
horrific rhino senator lisa murkowski
who's worse than a democrat
she's worse than a democrat
and how sullivan doesn't come out and
denounce her is amazing to me i'll tell
you
he called me up he was eight points down
and then i endorsed him and he ends up
winning his race how he doesn't denounce
lisa murkowski for what she's done to
this party and to your state
markowski
has been in the senate for 21 years her
father held a seat for 21 years before
she's a total creature of the washington
swamp but much worse than that
and a tool of a corrupt establishment
the likes of which we've never seen
the fake news media loves her
that's it itself
and one of the most destructive
two-faced rhinos she betrayed the alaska
voters she wiped out anwar
do you know that anwar
do you know that anwar is the biggest
site
maybe saudi arabia maybe maybe not
you had the biggest site ronald reagan
tried this did you know that mike ronald
reagan tried endlessly to get it
couldn't do it nobody could do it the
bushes you know they don't try so hard
what do they do they don't try
they're bush they've been lost for a
long time
so they didn't try that hard but they
tried
but they all tried for years decades and
decades they tried they couldn't get it
i got it and lisa murkowski approves a
person
that in the first day of office
wipes out and were now lisa murkowski
said i'm not going to vote for you
unless i have assurances of anwar for
alaska
they would have been paying you taxes
okay if you had that the biggest site
probably in the world right and it was
wiped out in one day by lisa murkowski's
approval she had the final vote
she could have made a deal could have
done something just remember she did it
because i know what's going to happen
you have that ranked choice crap voting
if you're in fifth place you get points
if you're in third place you get
how many people all right sarah palin
won but we had a couple of people in
second place we're going to give them
the victory right you know you got to
watch that this is really horrible
what's going on with our elections
so and so had five votes for fifth place
so we're going to give them the victory
it's crazy it's crazy and you know who
got it put in lisa murkowski got it
right
because she knows she knew just look at
the pulse she knew she could not win a
straight up election so she went for
crazy rank choice it's really not crazy
actually we've talked about it a couple
dozen times
said you won the election it's a total
rigged deal just like a lot of other
things in this country murkowski
repeatedly voted in favor of amnesty for
illegal aliens and she voted against
allowing funding for the border wall
that was that one good
this is what i had a fight against she
opposed brett kavanaugh's confirmation
to the supreme court he just gave you
the most important vote you've ever had
but she was against
she voted to approve joe biden's radical
left justice
kachengi
brown
the most far left
justice in history by a factor of about
six in fact i saw where she was bragging
she said in all the years i've been a
judge i have never once voted in favor
of trump i've never made a decision in
favor of trump
kendall kerr swami vive
but she's the most radical judge and the
most radical left judge
either way the most radical most radical
left and who approved her
lisa murkowski approved
voted to support
taxpayer-funded late-term abortions nine
months
the baby can be born like in virginia
remember the governor of virginia
the baby is born and then we'll sit down
with a mother and find out what we want
to do with it remember that guy well
that's basically what they're approving
but didn't exist that's basically what
they're doing and murkowski voted
in favor of it murkowski voted to
support joe biden's gun grabbing attack
on the second amendment i think the
people
i think the people of alaska
sarah is this correct kelly i think they
want their
guns i think they like the second
amendment
obviously not at this speech that'd be
crazy to be dangerous but elsewhere
[Applause]
it's like the fake news look at all them
back there look at all those cameras oh
the fake news
you know they said
president trump is very close it's too
close to coal in texas before the
election polls were showing me even and
texas guys were saying i don't know
about you but i know texas and he ain't
even in texas
so they're against guns
it was the closest result in texas i
think in something like 30 years
maybe more
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
okay
so they said that
before the race they said no texas is
too close you can't know it's going to
be very close right it's going to be
very everyone's saying what do you mean
close race how can you be against oil
and guns and god and it's going to be a
close race that trump's going to win it
by a lot anyway but the press says that
because if they can cheat
people aren't going to be so surprised
does that make sense you can't have a
20-point lead and then win
okay you can't do that where all of a
sudden you then lose so what happens is
they say oh it's going to be very close
i keep hearing this and yet i'd go and
would have crowds like this by the way
you set a new record today in the
history of alaska right
six million people
speak
do you know what's outside do you know
how many people are outside would
anybody like to leave now and let some
of the people outside come take it
well we set up some screens outside but
there are thousands of people outside
but this is a new record the arena
owners said this is a record that will
not be beaten
[Applause]
but a bigger record is what's outside so
anyway so let's finish so texas
so texas so you know the way on election
night
if you have a really insurmountable lead
they'll call it early right but they can
never call it until the door slows so
the door slows at eight o'clock like
eastern time so the doors are closed
and here's the ladies and gentlemen uh
the voting has stopped in texas donald
trump has won the state of texas i mean
meaning you won by so much wow that they
called it immediately
and i listened for three months as these
people back there were saying how close
this was going to be and this was true
with other states too
this was true with others so
the fake news and of course lisa
murkowski sided with the radical
democrats in the second impeachment hoax
and she voted to sham
and now think of this one they shamed
him she voted for the unselect committee
do you like that name on select
committee i'm very proud of it these are
these are the same people that gave you
the impeachment hoax number one the
impeachment hoax number two they voted
to sham that's crazy
[Applause]
although after two years
they did come out with a conclusion
think of this 18 trump haters
and they came out with a conclusion
right yeah when i was still kind of
drugged up after having my wisdom teeth
out i was making a lot more sense than
this say that okay
without notes you know we're not reading
this speech
we're not doing a lot of reading here
i know
because you know when you read it it
gets a little bit stale doesn't it
now think of it
no collusion after two years
but she voted for she was all for him
but she voted to impeach me and i did
more for this state than any president
in history and that piece of
voted to impeach me
[Applause]
[Applause]
i mean not only anwar i got you the
railroad i got you covered or whatever
do you guys think he'll do his thing
where he says teachers shouldn't be
allowed to teach transgender will that
be part of today's speech to prove it as
quickly as possible i got you the timber
cutting everything i've done more for
alaska than any president by far
by far
and murkowski's a bad person and dan
sullivan should never ever have
given her an endorsement dan sullivan
dan sullivan should be ashamed of
himself
murkowski's opponent
kelly chebaca
chewbacca
is it true america first year who will
never stab alaska voters in the back
alaska you're going to be in good shape
with kelly and by the way she's run
she's been running for a long time she
has run
i've never seen anybody run so hard and
we're proud of her she's great as your
state's commissioner of administration
you know she spent a lot of time in
government and did everything i heard
was phenomenal because
you know taking on a sitting person a
sitting senator governor whatever it's
always tough it's a very tough thing to
do
you're taking on the establishment
you're taking on all the rhinos you're
taking on a lot of people that don't
have the country's best will in some
cases not in all cases but
so i had to go and really do a lot of
research but you wanted it so badly and
i did and i heard the best things i
think i've ever heard about a candidate
and kelly fought tirelessly for alaska
taxpayers to stop corruption fraud and
abuse and as you're senator she will
defend alaska energy workers you got the
energy workers they're not working quite
like they were but
we'll get them back someday soon
and she'll stand up for alaska jobs
she'll protect the second amendment and
innocent life she will oppose radical
left judges and she will support the men
and women of law enforcement ice and the
border patrol kelly please come up
[Applause]
this should be nuts
[Applause]
alaska
let's
show president trump how much we love
him
uh okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is
a cult
[Applause]
this candidate's getting crushed right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
man this is this is like
weird in a lot of ways
[Applause]
[Applause]
right remember
under president trump we weren't just
energy independent
we were energy dominant
nothing has changed
he is absolutely right
that he is the one who gave us anwar and
no other president in the history of our
nation was able to do that thank you
president trump
[Applause]
president trump unleashed the power of
our resource industries he opened up the
tongass national forest for us
he gave us the road to ambler mine this
is good for our workers this is good for
our economy
president trump
rebuilt our military and what he left
out but we need to remember it was after
obama and biden decimated it
thank you president trump
president trump does not bend a knee to
bullies or bureaucrats or biden
but we can't say the same thing about
senator murkowski
no
guess what president trump
she's become biden's ceo
yeah she's his chief enabling officer
anything joe biden wants done
lisa murkowski delivers it
yep
joe biden wants gun control
lisa murkowski votes for it
joe biden wants to kill our oil and gas
industry
lisa murkowski puts the radical
environmentalists in place who are going
to execute that agenda
[Music]
but president trump and i have made
clear that for us it's always about
america first
and simply put that's why we love you
[Applause]
thank you kelly
she's going to be fantastic
she loves this state
in this primary alaskans also have the
chance to vote for a second alaska
conservative warrior
and elect her to congress someone that
you all know very well and
she was your favorite and you're she was
a favorite she was always a favorite of
mine i just thought she was incredible
she by the way she did a phenomenal job
when she went in
mccain went up like 10 points they
didn't appreciate what they had i'll
tell you they had
they had something that would have been
unbelievable they didn't appreciate it
and uh but there's nobody like this
woman i've known her so long she's loyal
she loves the state she will be a true
warrior for your state and for the
country
sarah palin
[Applause]
sir we need you back four more years
four more years
and president trump you are home
this is home
[Applause]
we love you
a lot of people asked me how did you
know that you know that president trump
that donald j trump was going to be the
best president that we'd ever had how
did how did you think to uh to get out
there and endorse them early when
gosh you know there was a lot of uh
party pressure on me and others to
endorse you know established candidates
and all that and um i knew well
personally speaking for years
donald trump
watched what the fake media the fake
news the lame stream media put my kids
through okay
remember this
the things that you guys did to my kids
donald trump he would write me a note
and he would say hang in there
the people who know you they love you
they know the truth about your family
sitting right over there god bless you
hi trig
[Applause]
and i knew that this man cared about
family he cared about a culture of life
and a culture of love and i knew way
back when
that if he ever did run
for hot the highest office in the land
the most powerful position
in the world
donald trump
he would do what he campaigned on doing
and isn't that rare he actually
fulfilled his promises
that's why he's not a politician
[Applause]
so he would he would once in a while jot
a note down saying hang in there and you
know ignore what they're saying he
always knew it was about the kids
because
i am a mama grizzly and i'll rear up on
my hind legs when somebody comes after
my cubs
he knew that so that
that really struck me my heart and
that's that's when i first like just
totally respected the man but then
along comes crooked hillary thinking
she's gonna get into the white house
[Applause]
and
i knew
out of all the candidates who were
running the established politicians
there was only one who wasn't a
politician thank the lord that was
donald trump
and i knew
out of all of them because i knew them
all
he was the only one who had the balls to
take on the fake media fake news and to
take on hillary clinton
and he did it for you he did it that's
why i love him
[Applause]
thank you both thank you sarah thank you
kelly really we really appreciate it
appreciate what you have to go through
once again the primary is august 16th
and mega conservatives need to turn out
in massive numbers to defeat the rhinos
the endorsements meant so much to so
many people we have so many victories
it's incredible and l thank you very
much for your help we appreciate it very
much and illinois where mary miller just
won and that was another one that people
said oh that won't happen and she's
going to be fantastic so everybody get
out and vote for sarah and kelly
we're pleased to be joined as well by
anchorage mayor
david bronson
[Applause]
wow they like you david
you never know when you do this
sometimes it doesn't work out that way
you understand you they like you a lot
david that's great thank you very much
thank you for being here
alaska gop chairwoman ann brown
thank you
thank you anne
[Applause]
somebody that's been with me for six
years the
and think of it six years does everyone
know jerry ward campaign in alaska it's
trump alaska and he's been doing it for
six years and all i know is we win by a
lot so he's got to be doing a good job
thank you jerry
thank you
and a friend of mine and a great guy i
know you heard him speak before i heard
he was fantastic mike lindell thank you
mike
great
thanks bud
a big star captain russell wildcat
newberry from deadliest catch we all
know him
big star
thank you thank you very much
thank you wildcat
thank you very much
and captain dino sutherland from
national geographic
alaska fish wars national geographic
that's great thank you very much thanks
great job thank you
over four incredible years and i have
been fighting for a long time i fought
for the
hard-working people of alaska like no
president in history has ever done we
passed
legislation opening the arctic national
wildlife
refuge
known as anwar for american energy
exploration and development which means
jobs jobs
jobs and it means industry and revenue
for the people of alaska and as i said
it may be the biggest site anywhere in
the world for
energy may be the biggest and in one day
because of murkowski it was gone
we're going to get it back for you i'm
telling you we're going to get it back
and it won't be hard the second day
all because of makowski we also issued
the first ever leases for oil and gas
production in the region never happened
unfortunately the biden administration
canceled those leases do you believe it
recently here we are we need energy we
need oil we need gas and they cancel
leases
and they waged a war on alaska energy
workers i don't know how the hell you
could vote for a democrat i really don't
and now our entire country is paying a
very steep price not only at the pump
all over and as our great fisherman will
tell you the soaring cost of fuel is a
disaster
for alaska fishers risking putting them
virtually out of business the two guys
know but
we have a lot of fishermen here we have
a lot of
but the cost of fuel and insurance and
everything else has gone
so high they've never seen not even
thinkable if somebody would have said
two years ago this could have happened
it could never have happened under my
administration we also issued a
presidential permit
for the a2a railroad between canada and
am i on
jobs and
facilitate the export of affordable
north american energy to
other countries that was a big one we
got it done quickly very quickly you
were even surprised by that right
they were trying to get that one done
for many many years we authorized the
crucial mining service road
to facilitate development in northwest
alaska ambler mining district
we approve permits for the alaska
liquefied natural gas pipeline project
crowd super engaged huh broadband access
and vastly expanded telehealth services
all over alaska especially in rural
alaska where you need it
[Music]
and i signed an executive order to
elevate the tragic issue of missing and
murdered native americans a big issue
a big big issue we gave your state a
critical exemption from damaging
restrictions against road constructions
and timber harvest you know what that's
all about everything everybody's doing
super keyed into that has incredibly
just reversed he just took it away all
those jobs
we stopped the obama era regulatory
assaults on hunting trapping fishing
gear
and ammunition and i stood up for our
hunters our fishers our sportsmen
our outdoorsmen
like no administration they say since
teddy roosevelt and maybe better
maybe better
when we win in november
kelly and sarah
republicans will fight and we will win
like never before for alaska we are
going to do it again
some of the things that we approved have
been
put by the wayside by the obama
administration and the woman and the
people that murkowski approved it's not
even believable one of the first things
we will do is stand up for parents
rights
[Applause]
is this gonna be the teach transgender
thing
it's time to finally and completely
smash the radical f's corrupt education
cartel it's crazy what's going on our
children are
captives to unhinge marxist educators
where do they come from who are pushing
inappropriate sexual racial and
political material in our children from
the youngest possible age
the public school system has become an
arm of the radical left and we are not
going to
allow this to happen we're not going to
we stopped it you know we had
we stopped it through executive order we
stopped it and many of those executive
orders have been ended at long last
every parent in america must be
empowered to opt out of this
indoctrination and send their child to
the public private charter religious or
home school
of their choice choice choice we want
choice
in addition we will get critical race
theory out of our schools out of our
military and out of every part of our
federal state and local governments
and where is it
and sometimes i'll have people and
certain things say like well but sir why
didn't you do it i said i did it was all
done
in the military all done everybody's
fired everybody gone they came back in
they ended it immediately and now we're
back to the same old stuff it's
unbelievable we will also keep men
out of
women's sports
[Applause]
who's crazier trump are the people
clapping for this right
the swimmer
the young swimmer she wanted to break
that record 1 16 of a second she was
going to do it
and she looked over and she said hello
to people that she's grown up with she's
seen him she's a top top swimmer she
looks left and she sees them hi hi you
know they hate each other but they're
you know they're competing hi hi they
hate her
she hates them that's the way life goes
right
then she looks over waves and then she
sees this
guy
they say i mean this is supposed to be a
technically
correct here
personally with a man's body okay it's a
man's body
so they seize this person with a man's
body and he's a giant he's that big
guy's wingspan
so mike he broke the record by 38
seconds
and she was injured by wind burn as he
went by her
now leah thomas also lost some races
right right i don't know if it's 218
pounds some large number of pounds
and this woman was so strong and she was
gonna lift it she was gonna lift that
weight over her he's gonna break the
record
wait lift weight wasn't it a swimming
thing i break the wreck they got chase
up there
[Music]
she didn't make it boom
this guy comes over right
oh god
have you lifted before no not really
i mean how crazy is this is this the
it's actually demeaning to women and it
shouldn't be allowed and a lot of people
don't talk about what trump's doing
right now isn't demeaning
[Applause]
people think it's politically incorrect
they think it's politically incorrect to
talk about it i don't somebody has to do
somebody has to do it
no teacher should ever be allowed to
teach
transgender to our children there it is
without parental consent there it is
[Applause]
now what does that mean to teach trans i
still don't even know they'll crack down
hard on big farmers
forgiving puberty blockers and other
dangerous jugs to mutilate are you
dangerous jugs
you have a kid go to school puberty
blockers
we will save our kids and every federal
bureaucrat who is complicit in this
travesty needs to
immediately be fired at least right
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
free speech in america
and go out by the way while i'm here and
sign up now for truth social it's hot as
a pistol and you see that i pull that
one right
leonard
elon
is not gonna buy twitter
where did you hear that before
from me
and me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess you know he
said the other day oh i've never voted
for a republican i said i didn't know
that he told me voted for me
so he's another [ __ ] artist but he's
not going to be buying it wow
he's not going to be buying it
although he might later who the hell
knows what's going to happen he's got a
pretty rotten contract i looked at his
contract not a good contract but he's
not sign up for truth
we love the truth um
[Applause]
radical left democrat party is not a 50
party
within our country
they're against god
they're against oil they're against guns
they're against law enforcement they're
against
voter id who's against voter id
they're only one reason you can be
against voter id because you want to
cheat there's no other reason
they're against tax cuts regulation cuts
they're against the constitution they
hate the constitution and they hate our
founding fathers other than that they're
quite nice i really like them
the way they win
with all these policies how can they win
i always said they're not 50 50 they
cheat in elections that's what i really
believe somebody would say what a
horrible thing to say about our republic
let me tell you they cheat in elections
and what trump means is he tries to
cheat in elections
much again i have to say it to
the supreme court of wisconsin because
they did
they finally
a court
was finally willing to do something
and say and
say it like it is
that's why we must pass critical
election integrity reforms including
universal voter id
citizenship confirmation can you believe
it we don't want citizenship
confirmation oh really
they don't want citizenship what's that
all about you don't have to be a citizen
to vote
no more fake drop boxes thank you
wisconsin no private money pouring into
local elections
no ranked choice kelly
no rank choice voting which can be
crooked as hell
right
it's actually pretty good
kelly chewbacca
kelly chewbacca
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have a big
development election evening
kelly chewbacca is number one but the
winner will be the one who's in third
place so thank you explain that
please explain that to me it's funny
because trump's like i should win even
though i'm in second place so it doesn't
sound that crazy we're stuck with it you
know why because of murkowski the only
way she could win it's the only way she
can win
and ultimately we need same-day voting
with only paper ballots that's what it's
all about
trump votes by mail by the way
[Applause]
what they should have
[Applause]
france big country just had an election
i think it was 38 39 million people
voted
paper ballots same day voting it ended
at like 11 o'clock they announced the
winner
the loser went home bye-bye
the winner said boy it was closer than i
thought but there were no questions
same-day voting
same-day voting
there were no questions because they
didn't have a lunatic like trump
claiming he won when he actually lost
military far away or if you're really
sick not sick like they were in
wisconsin where they're down in miami
beach
saying i'm very sick i can't do it i'm
on the beach
we're just four months away from the
most important midterm election in
american history true i'm gonna need a
landslide so big that the radical left
cannot rig or steal this election
this is the year we're going to take
back the house
we're going to take back the senate and
we're going to take back america
[Music]
wait trump can't rap without telling us
his plan on toilets can he 2024 most
importantly we are going to take back
our
magnificent white house
[Applause]
but first we have to secure massive
victories for kelly and sarah in this
primary so get your friends get your
family and get out and vote gotta do it
together we will fight for more jobs
for american families fair trade
for american workers look what i did
usmca remember they said nafta the worst
deal ever made in the history of trade
and we had it in fact mexico and canada
as you probably heard they want to
renegotiate the deal mexico you want to
renegotiate the price of air force one
boeing because they said
the deal that trump made while losing
our shirt that's something nice about
that isn't it can you imagine they want
to renegotiate the price and i'm sure
these people will do it
they're going to lose 600 million
dollars
and more american factories forging more
products
stamped with that beautiful beautiful
phrase made in the usa
trump's own campaign stuff came from
china titans border disaster reinstitute
our strong remain in mexico policy
strengthen the patriots of ice and
border patrol incredible people we will
again
end catch and release we will end chain
migration we will end the visa lottery
and we will click melania's parents are
here due to chain migration less than
two years ago
[Music]
how about i got through very good
negotiation i got a thing called remain
in mexico they have to remain in mexico
the killers and everybody else that
wants to come in
and biden ended it
he ended it do you believe it he ended
it so now they can remain in the united
states
and never never have to leave we will
stop the crime wave in democrat-run
cities most cities are done by run by
democrats safe ones and more dangerous
ones deserve and let them do their job
the way only they know how to do it and
we will not take legal protection away
from our police
we will restore
law and order in america we will hold
china accountable for unleashing the
most vicious virus
that anybody has ever seen
upon the world
we will protect innocent life we will
defend our constitution
we will defend the second amendment
which is under siege and we will proudly
uphold
the judeo-christian values and
principles of our nation's
founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and always always always respect
our great american flag
including
i love this guy's shirt
in collusion i'd love to have you get up
here come on get up here let me see get
up here get this guy up here uh-oh come
here i love this guy any guy wears a
shirt like that how can you not love him
look at that beautiful yeah would you
help him up taylor help him up come on
you're a strong guy come here i just
want to show it i love this shirt
he completely glitched on in conclusion
so now he's bringing someone on the
stage i like that one
[Music]
i want this shirt i'm going to wear it
to the next round
oh i love that shirt come on up here sir
please
oh no
i want it
[Applause]
oh boy
oh boy
wait who's this other person here
[Applause]
you know that was a really bad glitch
for him to bring people wearing that on
the stage
this must have been the glitch to end
all glitches that caused them to call
them up
in conclusion
our omega movement make america great
again
is by far the greatest political
movement
in the history of our country
you know we've had some movements we've
never had one like this it's pillow
you know you've had movements where
a politician like came in second by the
way they took their shirt off as if
trump really wants the shirt trump has
spent his entire life trying to stay
away from basically everybody at this
rally
we won
all of them we won all of them we won
every one of them
nobody's ever seen anything like it we
won every one of them all 50 plus the
islands you don't know about the islands
but the islands too
there's never been a movement and then
we won the election twice
we won it twice
we may have to do it again
together we're standing up against some
of the most menacing forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents our
people
have ever seen the way they throw around
the word impeachment the way they go
after
people that are innocent people
political people and yet they leave
killers on the street to shoot people
big massive
great outside dangers our biggest threat
remains the sick sinister and evil
people from within our country but no
matter how big or powerful these corrupt
radicals may be
you must never forget this nation does
not belong to them
this nation belongs to you
[Applause]
this is your home this is your heritage
and our american liberty is your
god-given right remember that they want
to take that away
from anchorage to fairbanks and
wasilla to juno
from the slopes of
denali
to the waters of glacier bay that's a
beautiful place
and from the forests of the interior to
the majestic vistas of
the inside passage does anybody know the
inside passage
[Applause]
anybody want to go there tonight what a
beautiful name the inside let's go to
the inside passage tonight right
yeah by the way
is there anything that's more fun than a
trump rally
especially that 15-minute story trump
told earlier
[Applause]
this state was forged by some of the
very toughest men and some of the very
strongest women ever to walk
the face of the earth
they didn't have a lot of money they
didn't have
a lot of luxury but they had grit they
had faith
and they had each other very importantly
they were frontiersmen and fishermen and
lagers and lumberjacks and homesteaders
and miners
and they poured out their heart and
their sweat and their soul to make
america into the greatest nation
in the history of the world
but now we are a nation in decline
we are a failing nation
we are a nation that has the highest
inflation in over 40 years
where the stock market just finished the
worst first half of a year
in more than five decades
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy cost in its history
and we are no longer energy independent
or energy dominant which we were just
two
short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
venezuela and saudi arabia for oil
please
please give us essentially none of these
things are true but it's hard to fact
check all of them one after another
nation in the world but we're begging
them for
oil
we're a nation that surrendered in
afghanistan
leaving behind dead soldiers and
american citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
in the world
we are a nation that allowed russia to
devastate a country ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse
and it never would have happened
if the election were different would
have never happened
it didn't happen all of those people
that are now dead in all of those cities
that are now crushed
nothing would have happened
we could have made a deal but we didn't
even have to make a deal nothing would
have happened
it would have never happened i believe
he saw what happened in afghanistan
and he said these people don't know what
they're doing this is our chance i
really believe that but it never would
have happened putin would have never
done it
all of that human life
and that culture in those cities
we're a nation that has weaponized its
law enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before we've
never seen anything like this we're a
nation that no longer has a
free and fair press
fake news is about all you get
and they are the
true enemy of the people
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed
where crime is rampant like never before
where the economy has been collapsing
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020.
we are a nation that is allowing iran to
build a massive nuclear weapon would
have never happened they would have made
a deal in the first week
and china to use the trillions and
trillions of dollars it's taken from the
united states
to build a military to rival our own
and perhaps most importantly we are a
nation
that over the past two years
is no longer respected or listened to
all around the world
we are a nation that in many ways has
become a joke
true and we are a nation that is hostile
to liberty and freedom and faith
we are a nation whose economy is
floundering whose stores are not stocked
whose deliveries are not coming and
whose educational system is ranked at
the bottom of every list
but we are not going to let this
continue two years ago
we had many of those things are true but
they have nothing to do with joe biden
it's been a decline and it's a cultural
issue as well everybody african-american
hispanic-american asian-american women
men
high school diploma
[Applause]
people with no diploma from high school
people with phds from
mit and harvard and the wharton school
of finance and all of these great
schools everybody was doing well
women especially women doing well
everybody
but soon we will have greatness again
it was hard-working patriots like you
who built this country and it is
hard-working patriots like you who are
going to save our country we will stand
up to the radical left lunatics and the
rhinos and we will fight for america
like no one has ever fought before get
rid of lisa mikowski get rid of lisa
there is no mountain we cannot climb
right there is no summit we cannot reach
there is no challenge we cannot meet
there is no victory we cannot have
we will not bend we will not break
we will not yield ever ever ever
kelly
sarah
they will never
ever
do that
we will never give in we will never give
up and we will never ever back down
as long as we are confident and united
the tyrants we are fighting do not stand
even a little chance
because we are americans and americans
kneel to god and god alone
my fellow citizens
this incredible journey
we are on together has only just begun
and it is time to start talking about
greatness
for our country greatness again
we don't talk about greatness anymore we
talk about problems we talk about crime
we talk about taking power away from our
police
we talk about a woke military do you
believe this
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious american nation
so with the help of everyone here today
and the citizens all across our land
we will make america powerful again
we will make america wealthy again
[Applause]
we will make america strong again so
small
we will make america proud proud proud
proud again
we will make america safe
again
and we will make america great again
thank you very much alaska thank you
thank you alaska
thank you god bless you all
well there he goes
[Music]
dear god
[Music]
[Applause]
what an event huh
[Music]
well trump will sort of uh
skulk off the stage momentarily here a
very very unusual speech
uh
trump visibly struggling to
[Music]
use
words to communicate
meaning
uh
and it's sort of hard to
hard to say more about it
um i really do appreciate everybody who
was here
and uh charged that to the game and
dr gekko getting in their twitch prime
subscriptions before you head out would
love for you to get those uh twitch
prime subscriptions in our friends small
fuzzy moss is here
small fuzzy moss many people don't know
this responsible for many
um of the elements on our sound board
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines always great to see
small fuzzy ma slip and shank coming in
at number 149
can we get to 150 on the way out we're
almost there there it is one lucky duck
pushing us over to 150.
we'll be live during the week with the
january 6 committee hearings these may
be the last ones it's never totally
clear
to be honest i don't know what's going
on with that
committee schedule but we'll cover the
entire thing
it's going to be great
and on your way out make sure you're
following on twitch make sure you've
liked on facebook make sure you've
subscribed
on uh youtube it's all free and the more
you subscribe the more i stream that's
the crazy thing about it all right
everybody we'll see you very soon thank
you for joining me
and try not to become completely
despondent by the horrors or the hara as
bernie would say of what we've seen
tonight there are still good people
there are still reasonable people
they just weren't at this rally they
just weren't at this rally all right
good night everybody
you